Hello, hello, hello!
Oh, okay, good.
Moe, boo!
Owe, boo!
Okairin'asai Masai, Koshichi, Zaba, Hi!
Hello, hello!
Welcome in, everybody!
Hi, hoi, hoi, hoi, hoi I say hi, hi, hi, hi.
You guys say hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi!
Hi, hoi, hoi, hoi!
Hi.
Welcome back to Retro Revind.
Is this enough to cover my late fee?
You must pay with your soul.
Is your soul worth five dollars?
Thanks for the rose, William.
Sorry for serious streaming.
Yeah, I'm seriously streaming.
My soul's not worth a penny.
What are you saying?
Don't say that.
Your soul is worth two pennies.
At the very least.
Actually, pennies are rare now.
Pennies are not in production anymore.
Right?
Am I...
Did I just make that up?
No.
I believe that they have been...
They are...
They are no longer.
Oh, it's true!
I am correct!
I knew it!
So!
You are a rarity.
They didn't have them at McDonald's today.
What are you doing at McDonald's?
Here's my soul.
No takebacks.
Hey, dog!
What do I need?
Oh, my cough is a little ugh today.
I kind of want McDonald's now.
McDonald's fries just like hit, you know?
Hello, Mito and I booze like you!
Hopefully Streamlabs doesn't bug out on me today.
This one comes through at a reasonable time.
Tee!
But no matter, I'm just glad to hang out with Mito!
Thank you, Kodo!
Oh, Mito.
finals fries are goaded i'm right did someone mention coins
she's she's gonna start hoarding stuff hi how are you
feeling i'm getting bit better every day i uh i was able to
sleep yesterday yippee um uh what was i saying oh just my
cough is just a little bit wonky today but that's okay
that's it so sorry if i'm just like sometimes have you seen
the new urpal nugget mcdonald's size urpal like uh uh like
uh my brain wants to say bowser but his name is not bowser
Grimbo...
Gr...
Thank you for the birthday, Dream.
Liz, it's our light!
Happy birthday!
Grimmas!
Grimmas... Grimmas.
Did you guys ever have the Grimmas shakes?
Did you freak a zoid freak out?
Did you like... Did you... Did you...
Did you... Did you strip naked and dump it all over
yourself?
Yeah, I died.
No.
It was mid.
Wait, what was the flavor?
I did, but then I died.
You got God by Grimmis.
Sugar.
Vanilla?
Oh, no way.
Is that...
Is that vanilla?
I haven't even heard of them.
Okay, a couple years ago.
It's been a couple years now, right?
Actually, I don't remember.
All time.
is so strange.
Pixel Bunny, welcome back!
There was a grimace shake being sold at McDonald's.
I had a grimace shake and just woke up from the coma.
Just now!
We brought it back!
We did it!
Welcome back!
It's three or four years ago.
That long ago now, well.
I'm afraid it's been.
Nine years.
Beep, beep, beep.
But...
Wait, no, it's been a decade?
No.
I think the Grimmest Shake was a U.S.
only thing.
That's why I'm explaining it.
So yeah, McDonald's made this, like, Grimmest Shake.
Which Grimmest is a character of McDonald's.
He's the big purple-looking one.
He's the...
How you like...
my nuggies guy that one tasted like purple how i get it
though i think
but they made it they made it and it i don't know how it
started but people started like drinking making videos of
drinking the grimace shake and then like it would be and
then it would like hard cut to it like splattered and I
think he's supposed to be a taste bud
why is he grimacing then honestly the whole guy makes no
sense yeah it was like borderline horror
so and then sometimes they got like really freaky like they
would be like making scary faces or they would be like sent
to the back rooms or something like yeah literal sugar coma
yeah it was like silly and it was scary and it was just you
know it was one of those times when you felt like the
internet was a little united you know sometimes the internet
feels divided and sometimes we all come together for like a
single trend that everyone's like
Hello.
Hi, Mito.
People just having fun.
Yeah.
We love that.
We love people just having fun.
So, but I never got to try the Grimmest Shake.
I never did it.
Maybe for the best.
I wonder what would have happened to me.
Yeah.
Did you see a Japanese McDonald's do a churnal?
Perfect math class and bad apple.
I saw the bad apple.
one.
I did not see the Chirno one.
But I saw Japanese McDonald's did one for my favorite Haruji
song, which is Yuki's uh, gosh, what's it?
Yuki, what's the name of it?
It's like a really long title.
But her image song.
Oh, it was so good!
It was so good!
I like that one.
Reincarnation?
If I drank the Grimmishake?
No, not Harehare Yukai.
It's the one that goes...
Yeah, you give one!
Yes, that one.
That song is so good.
Did you play the Grimmest Birthday Game Boy game?
I didn't.
I didn't play that either.
Can't say I'm...
up to date on my McDonald's, uh, anything, maybe.
Have you been fooled by any April Fool's jokes in JP Twitter
yet?
Oh my gosh, I literally sent one to Phoebe and Vicky
earlier.
I sent one to them earlier and I was like, oh my gosh.
I can never remember.
I don't know what it is.
I don't remember April Fool's.
Literally every single year I forget about it.
And then, it sneaks up on me, and especially right now,
because I'm coming back from my trips and being sick, and I
don't even know what month, what day it is at all.
That's why I haven't made a schedule for this week or
anything.
May April snuck up on all of us this year, I think.
Right!
And so, Japanese Twitter, they love doing April Fool's,
though, and they do it so well, I feel.
So basically my interface for my microphone is the Yamaha
AG08, right?
And yesterday, a friend mentioned that the current event in
Blue Archive is giving free swimsuit Koharu, and I instantly
thought of you.
That's a lot.
Wait.
Unless there was a new event.
Wait, did a new event start?
Wait.
Uh-huh.
Also, hi, Minto.
Hello, Eric.
We archive is the worst April Fool's jokes because it's
always something you actually want.
They're always like fun mini games and things.
Finally caught a stream of yours for once.
Like adorable series rule.
Also hi chat.
Play on play on fun.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
But, um, and thanks for the words.
Can I rent a freaky Ghost Maid 3?
Yo, we got the...
We got the...
Sequel plus one.
Trifecta.
Winter.
Why can't I...
What is after sequel?
Trilogy!
My goodness.
The trequel.
That's what I kept thinking.
The trilogy.
Okay.
um yes we um i was talking with den setsu yesterday and i
was we were we were kind of like giving each other like mic
recommendations and we were trying to like we're trying to
like min-max our travel setups because we travel me so i
feel like i travel quite often nowadays unfortunately and so
we're like what mics were good but are lightweight to to use
and what interfaces are good but also not gonna break the
bank and also lightweight and everything and you know
obviously I've they both bought like my little mini PC set
up and they both really like it so but I told them I have
the AG08 the Yamaha AG08 and I told them how I had got the
AG03 as my travel one because it's version of my current one
so I already know everything about it but I used it for MGS
con it was my first time using it and for some reason it
kept having feedback issues like I would play music and then
it would like double and I was like what I is there
something wrong like maybe you know the way that I use the
AG08.
It's obviously the AG03 is missing some of the features.
Also, thank you guys so much for all the super chats.
I'll read them in just a second after I go off on my
tangent.
I don't want to get distracted again and have to constantly
be repeating.
But so I was just like, yeah, um, you know, I really liked
it because it was fairly lightweight and I really like my
AG08.
So I really wanted to like this but I just couldn't get it
to work and um you know I only used it that once but I was
so like off put by it that I just immediately when I got
home I returned it immediately um but the reason I brought
this up is because the Yamaha Twitter account posted a a
plushie they were like they were like they were like today
we're announcing a plushy version of the ag03 that we're
going to be selling and i sent it to them and i was like
this is the one that i literally talked about yesterday it's
so cute maybe i was too hard on it and then it literally had
hashtag april fools I just I just I just I saw You know your
eyes just see what it wants to see And That's it Happy
retroing me too I hope you're feeling better Looking forward
to all the dance at two events In and around Ofka Yay Thanks
Wait are you gonna be there for his time I know you traveled
for For the jazz show Which is crazy enough Adiris, welcome
back!
Yoshi Kiwi, welcome back!
Japan announced no game, no live season 2.
That's also April Fools, isn't it?
I'm watching live, let's go!
Definitely welcome back!
I started beekeeping as a hobby recently and caught my first
ever wild swarm of bees recently.
I'm gonna have amazing honey eventually.
Also, should I dye my bee suit mint green in honor of my
Oshi?
There was a bee in my maid cafe today.
I was so... actually it wasn't a bee.
It was like a wasp and I was terrified.
are you seeking are your bees seeking to my maid cafe thank
you vanilla for this over time thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you watch a
clip of yours playing this game and since i unironically
love vhs it piqued my interest do you actually want do you
actually recommend it p.s the women in this game are yes
they are yes they are horny this is a fun game i think it's
very it's like chill enough but also i i enjoy games where i
am given task and i do task and do another thing you know
yeah i had a wasp in my maid cafe and it's so funny because
pause my cat she is such a good guards cat she is a great
guards cat and she's also a good huntress cat and she i
walked out of my room and i saw her on the couch.
And she gets on the couch, but not the top of the couch.
She was on the tippy top of the couch, and she was just
staring at the ceiling.
And I was like, what's there, girl?
What's that?
Old old wasp is stuck in the whale?
But is the cursor little minto?
Yeah, that's my cursor.
But yeah, so she was staring at the wasp on my ceiling.
I was like,
So afterwards I gave her choo-doo for being such a good
guards cat.
I'm afraid, Mito, you're no longer my Oshi.
April Fool?
April Fool's, right?
Oh my gosh, phrase nah.
First part of April Fool's joke.
that when a company jokes about new product and it makes you
go but i want it right april fools you're my kamiyoshi
meinto love you scared me you scared me
imagine having a useful huntress cat and not free for free
loaders I'd say your cat earned her keep.
I agree.
She's always finding little critters.
And then I have a vacuum with a long suck.
So I use it.
I go up to the bug.
And I just suck it.
And it gets trapped in there.
And it spins with all the dust.
And then it dies in there.
It's got a long sucker.
So I just...
I can feed from far.
away.
I could be from far away.
out of danger.
I want to go out like that.
Vacuum?
The word is vacuum.
Yeah, I said I have a vacuum with a long suck.
I don't know.
What do you call it?
A long tube?
I don't know.
Be too big.
Sounds like something you'd find in an adult section.
Nozzle?
Hose?
Oh, a hose maybe.
But it's like, when I think of a hose, hoses are kind of
soft, right?
It's the 31st in my time zone.
So still, so no, I mean it when I say you're Mayoshi and
you're only a little stinky today.
I will shower after the stream.
Please!
Gizar, thank you!
It's still the 31st for me too.
Nozzle extension.
Yeah!
That's a good way to put it.
Splug-o!
Thank you!
Almost 24 months.
What are you talking about?
It says 29!
You guys are like my personal dictionary when I don't
remember words, which is often.
I'd like to complain about the video title recommended to me
It was awful Please don't tell me the exact location of
where I can get more I feel like Our little video here is
quite boring Bloody Wizard It's not inspired at all It just
feels It's just boring
I'm bored We need better movies And that's why my shop
exists sounds like a doom metal band still would watch
really I mean maybe maybe it might be interesting I don't
know this doesn't seem very like
but let's play the game baby we have our store value is
almost $800.
Let's go.
We're on day eight.
We're killing it.
Was this...
Is this brand new today?
Look how beautiful it's becoming here.
Oh, I can hide in here.
Oh, yeah.
I can just sit here.
I can be like...
When someone walks by, I'm like, You want to come to my
movie store?
Hold on.
We'll wait for the next person.
Sucking nozzles, can't escape.
You want to come to my movie store?
Thank you so much for the movie.
No!
You want to come to my movie store?
Nobody's walking this way.
Everybody's walking the opposite way.
But yes, we are ghostbusters, baby.
Are you trying to get punched.
Ooh, this guy's not having a good day.
You know what would free him?
A movie?
Oh, never mind.
He's having a good day now.
Was it because he saw me?
All right, what were we doing?
Oh, no, we do have the new release.
Okay, I think we're on a new day then.
I think we got our snacks.
We have no movies returned.
I think we're at the beginning of a brand new day, baby.
Let's go.
Paying my late fee for a movie.
Oh, a skew.
Thank you.
Thank you, bacon.
Where do I end for the skew?
A scientist and his snake!
A boy.
Why isn't these two early in stream?
No!
Don't worry, would you apologize?
I'm sorry for not seeing it.
Wait.
New SKUs, new SKUs.
Thank you, everybody.
Send me the SKUs.
Let's see.
We have...
6, 9, 2, 9, 1, 4, 6, 4.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
That's embarrassing.
Grip my princess by the tip.
Wait, I don't have enough money.
for this this one is insane ma'am you're almost broke yes i
just realized that this is insane this one is actually let's
try the next one six nine eight four zero nine but it's fine
we're about to start the day so we'll make money dripping on
the teddy bear why are they all adult
regret that's like all i have that one's a romance
the depressed race
uh all right let's see what we got here oh we this is okay
so this is we spent all our money on our new release the
color violet so we're gonna we're gonna handle that and yeah
one star everyone's a hater all right come on in come on in
come one come all to my don't say wow movies give me bad
what bad vibes come come come come come oh you're already on
your way here you're already on your way oh you both are on
your way here what about you having a bad day you your way
here?
Wait, wait, don't leave, don't leave, don't leave, don't
leave.
Hello?
Oh, oh, movies give me bad headaches.
I don't like being pressured to buy.
Wait, I need more flyers.
Oh, yes, baby.
Oh, wait, we have a lion.
Oh, oh, we have people.
We have people waiting for us.
Okay, we'll just go back.
Hmm.
Hello, hello!
Oh, oops.
Wrong thing.
I haven't got much, but this is my best.
Oh, I will check it in one second.
What'd you get?
The keyboard blast off!
Oh.
You're free to go.
The color violet!
You got it, you got it.
Two dollars.
I'm getting back into the swing of things, baby.
Can't believe my Oshi is haunting my city twice!
Can't wait to see you on Baname Off-Kai and it's a 2A-XE
concert!
What was that sausage in the Moonbase 42?
Awesome.
What do you want?
You reserved.
Yes.
There you go.
Doe-zo?
Body part alien invasion.
It's not an adult film, ma'am.
Just giving you a heads up.
Thank you, Psychic Maniac!
I see you there!
See you there!
$13.
Thank you for your business.
You're free to go.
The Blood Sucking Paladin.
Yeah.
I've watched that three times this week.
Holy!
Uh, $5.
What moment, please?
They created the...
Oh, I have it, probably.
Oh, my gosh, everything's flying off the shelves right now.
I think we had recently unlocked the snacks.
Yeah, we got the snacks.
You are getting multiple adult movies.
Ma'am?
I'm telling you guys.
Why do I need to buy anything else?
I guess not everybody wants an adult film, but still.
I'm not shaming it's all the ladies in this town.
I swear They are they they they go for it
They I swear they love jork in it.
I guess so Hello Science fiction science fiction for you.
I suggest The Sorcerer living on Mars.
Fantastic pick, I know.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, come on.
A fee here, a bill there.
Why does everything in this world revolve around money?
Don't charge me.
I hope this fee helps you keep the lights off.
Why do you say that angrily?
I hope you...
I...
I hope that you're warm.
well fed like hello sure me too it does actually help me
keep the lights on i hope you have a nice day you still have
the hot t-rex movie not not that i'm interested actually
that actually did get rented just earlier oh emma she's back
We did have, um, wait, the color violet is not, dang, okay.
Joshua, my best customer.
It's not flying off the shells like I thought it would.
Hmm.
Thank you.
Maybe, um, we do some returns?
Maybe.
Oh, late.
Because I think we're running out of sci-fi.
And I think we're also probably...
Wait, what did I say?
Oh.
Last movie I recommended was terrible.
A good movie.
Okay, give me a second.
Horror.
Science fiction.
Drama.
I'm adult.
Yeah, we're constantly out of adult films, you guys.
It's kind of insane.
Bad critic, bad critic.
Uh-oh.
The science fiction?
Good critic!
Here you go.
Oh.
That's exactly what you were looking for, I know.
Wait, I thought that the new movie would like be crazy
popular, but it's not.
Hmm.
Are we making good money, you guys?
You're charging me a late fee?
Me?
Do you know who I am?
I won't pay this.
Charge him.
They're reminding me of the...
I hope you have a very nicer Christmas clip.
What is that?
I guess customer loyalty doesn't mean much here.
Sorry, Joseph.
If you were loyal, you wouldn't have screwed me over if
somebody was wanting that movie.
Probably.
I think.
oh for your color violet movie it's a themed night everybody
how cute yeah loyal customer repay their fees thank you very
much you are free to go what can i help you with all right
sweetheart we're all grown-ups here pick me an adult movie
you think i will enjoy well charles we have a leaky font oh
sorry a leaky loom and that's about it.
So, uh...
pick, he says.
You're lucky that she didn't grab it first.
I thought Susan was actually gonna take it.
Not gonna lie.
Oh no, close the door to finish the day.
You're our final customer.
Oh, yeah!
And he's a great customer.
Charles
If I I want to try Okay good I just wanted to make sure If I
accidentally gave too much I could like you know One of the
reasons Early Netflix took off against Blockbuster Was no
late fees Just saying Yeah but I'm running a business here
And you know what Netflix has done Raise their prices Crazy
like There's ads on Netflix now You guys Oh Oh
There was a skew I missed earlier.
It was in a super chat.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know if I can grab it now.
I'll try.
Thank you so much, though, for the super chat and for the
skew.
Thank you.
Netflix keeps going up.
The quality keeps going down.
Tisk, tisk, tisk.
I have no space.
I hope somebody doesn't want, uh...
What is this?
Skull brain implants!
Wait, this is...
is so good.
It's been rented six times.
People love it.
Um, maybe we can win the last time you've been.
Five.
The scary marine.
Oh, everybody loves it.
Okay.
And then all of our adult movies.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you get an adult movie and you don't rewind it.
Where are the Super Nintendo games?
Don't worry.
When we expand, we're gonna get a whole new adult section.
Thank you!
Uncle Spooky!
I got you.
Thank you.
I wish there was like a cheap forest troll racer.
Oh, it's cheap and it's a good spooky prize.
Wait, what's this one?
bodies.
Did I get my poster?
Yes, I did.
Troll racer.
Oh my god, we're having the whole G-force, like, everything.
People love it.
I think we did everything.
I think we're good to go.
Don't Don't apologize for being late.
What are you talking about?
Can we, I think we'll be able to hire someone after today.
Let's see.
We unlocked action movies!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
You left that movie in the floor and you have...
No, I don't think that's a horror shelf.
That's my sci-fi shelf.
Oh, I do a...
You're right.
Everybody, you're right.
Oops.
You're right.
Oh wait, can I hire now?
Employees.
Level 6.
I think I'm level 5.
God.
Okay.
Shelves.
Let's get a big one.
A biggin.
Holy, that was like all my money.
Wait.
And then it'll give us like a free thing, right?
10 random movies.
Yeah, for free.
Nice.
Milk out of time.
Oh, Toon.
I thought I was out of time.
Project Love Seat X.
A killer breakfast in our home.
We're at the fast food hacker.
These are so good.
Bathroom carnage.
Kill the mushroom.
killer foot.
Yeah.
I'm almost out of money, though.
The cupcake separation.
Queen cyber attack.
The breakup over the elephant.
You know what that reminds me of?
It's like the meme where it's like the elephant and it's
like, address me.
Kings diver.
The cassette's last day home.
All right, all right, all right.
Brain implants!
No way, someone really did want it.
That's crazy.
This is a popular movie, I think.
Skew, but you didn't hear it from me.
A default text sign is killing me.
Thank you for your...
Wait, what was it?
Let me see the skew.
Actually, if you guys could send the skews as stream labs,
it will make it much easier for me to look at them.
make sure that they don't go through chat because i might
miss it gargling spears bath water
it's it's half a star no it's so expensive too i recently
had to oil up my antique gumball machine so i rented what i
thought was an inspirational video after viewing the film
five times i can confirm it was not as advertised it's 8.5
out of 10 experience thank you very much for your business
bye bye bye all right oh i see a dinosaur one let's go this
is a cool sci-fi and this is a cool horror the killer
breakfast oh let's go get our new shelf
oh yeah we're gonna put it okay now it's starting to become
like a real oh it's huge though maybe okay hold on let's do
this Let's move these to here.
And we'll put this against the wall.
What color should action be?
There we go.
That looks cleaner.
You are...
Hmm.
Blue?
That was my birthday!
No joke, can I get a happy birthday for my coming?
Oh, CPS.
I've been missing the concert VOD since it got taken down.
Lavi!
Happy birthday!
Feliz compil años!
I'm sorry, hopefully the concert VOD can come back someday.
Let's do!
Yellow.
Oh, that looks better.
Happy birthday!
action movies we got 10 of them we got a rare one we have no
beggar on the farm apocalyptic statue oh wait this is like
they're like mmm we don't we have drama as blue no cask on
the farm I like the chicken with the guns Martian storm fury
blazing enchanter the siege of the the giant rooster.
Dragon team.
The last hope.
I would watch that.
We'll need another concert soon then.
Well, July is sooner than you think.
It's already April tomorrow.
April for some of you watching, maybe.
Wow.
Ultraman.
Oh, Ultraman!
The gesture returns.
Gesture burnout.
We got two shinies.
Nuclear sorcerer warfare.
fair someone's already a killer breakfast in our home i just
bought that oh yeah baby april fool's incoming i'm already
being fooled as we speak what the trophy robots
maybe i should turn it towards me though because then i can
see if it's out of stock or not.
We don't have much sci-fi right now.
Actually, oh, we do have more stuff to...
We do have these.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
Uh, horror.
Yeah, okay.
Alright.
Yeah, we got lots of stuff waiting for us.
Maybe we'll, uh...
Oh.
Maybe we'll get some more sci-fi coming back in.
Super Mr. Death Lord, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Dropping him like it's nothing.
I take...
Oops.
Dang it.
I take care of my...
Of my...
My stock.
All right.
I could take good care.
What is this?
The heirloom love affair.
That sounds spicy.
That sounds like it could be quite dramatic.
Lay.
I like how many movies there are that are like freaky and
about ghosts.
Uh-oh.
I don't think I have a second drama.
Thank you, I have no money though, we can still see what it
is.
9, 0, 7, 0, 8, 0, 2.
Oh, I keep doing this, I keep putting different numbers,
that's so weird.
Oh, it's so, it's so expensive.
It has no stars.
Sweaty hot dog action!
Oh, that means it's amazing.
That get off the computer key is a fantasy.
No stars.
Oh, that means it's so...
That has to be a cult classic right there.
Okay, today is like a nothing day.
Tomorrow is...
What is that?
A meteor shot.
Oh, sci-fi movie rentals.
Okay.
We might want to get some more sci-fi then.
The ghost muffin.
fantasy.
Thanks for the hot dogs!
Where can I find Ghostbusters?
I know you might be asking that because we have literally
the finest movies.
Hot
dog!
Hi doggy diggy dog dog.
Oh, hot dog.
Very nice!
I think we're good to go then.
I think we're good to open.
Hello.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to do that.
You still like that?
Hmm.
Maybe some other time.
Why was that a negative?
Ooh.
I'm trapped in there.
Yeah, you're coming to deliver stiff PC.
You're just holding it out.
Open.
You want to see that you grabbed it.
Yeah, we know.
We know what you are.
Yes, you did.
Hello!
$13.
Any day now.
Ryan.
$1.
You're free to go.
I feel like I need to go do more flyers though.
I need to get more people in.
There's people walking.
They're out.
Yes.
Sorry, I didn't mean to jump.
Got really excited.
About money.
Been so excited about money.
I'm losing out on potential customers.
They're all walking by.
They just don't use their eyes.
They know they want movies.
But they just don't know it yet.
You don't know it yet.
Come on, we gotta get out here.
We gotta spread the good word.
Oh, you don't own a VHS player.
Honey, get with the times.
It's 1999.
A new release has been new.
I wonder if it's a bug because it says it's only supposed to
be new for a week.
Too many people going.
No?
One moment, please!
Oh, you're returning?
Why?
Why don't you like a movie?
Please!
Oh!
She's gonna be the DVD creator.
We don't know it yet.
I'm not completely VHS-related, but I remember one time I
went to a rental store with a DVD.
When I went to return it, I said to the counter, as a joke,
don't worry, I already remounted it and she looked at me
like I was crazy.
That's a funny joke, Fettuccine.
That's good.
That's like something a dad would say.
Oh, skull brain implants.
Yeah.
You got lucky, man.
You got lucky.
It flew off the shelf.
It was the only thing on there.
Very dad-coded.
Guys, we're making no money.
It's 2.30 p.m.
and we haven't even broken a hundred.
Be kind, rewind.
How about be kind, don't charge the fee?
Well, it is what it is.
Yep, exactly.
Thank you.
She's going to be the Blu-ray creator.
Extra hater.
A single dollar.
Thank you.
You're free to go.
I'm surprised more people aren't getting the color violet.
I feel like 13 bodies was always getting rented.
Like we cleared out.
Not even my rare one is getting got...
How's our shelf?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
You didn't know we were here, did you?
What do you mean, humph?
No!
Potential customer, please come back!
movie candy and why is it Buncha Cruncher?
I think the best movie candy is popcorn.
I'll stand by popcorn forever.
I'm popcorn's biggest fan.
Hello.
Trophy robots?
Choo!
Thank you!
Hell yeah, popcorn.
Huh?
I one from the tape hole I swear okay I will I will check
them out after today's day thank you for the for the donuts
you guys thank you huh oh what were you doing over there huh
what were you doing over there um actually it's junior mince
okay I do like junior mince yeah I love the beast freak show
it's such a Layla, you're gonna think it's the best movie
ever.
You're gonna love this movie, I swear.
What did you get?
What did you get, you little freak?
The saucy snake delivery.
Yeah, you put it on top, didn't you, Brittany?
Killer breakfast.
Thank you.
Twizzlers are my go-to mood.
Oh, twizzlers are good.
You guys are gonna make me hungry.
Guys, you're making me hungry.
She wants you to take note of what she's...
She's like, do you get what I'm putting down?
I was like, well, you're getting what you put down, because
it's your movie.
You're free to go.
Come on, I don't have all day.
I have potential customers outside.
We need someone to run the register, like, that.
Eric, thanks for the hot dog.
Oh, are you ready?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Thank you.
You're free to go.
That point will come soon.
We're so close.
Can I get more people?
No, don't leave.
Don't leave.
You're a customer.
Yeah!
Ooh!
Exactly.
Ah!
No!
Why is the ground steaming?
Ooh!
Why are you a hater?
I like that when you hand them the flyer, too.
They leave.
They're like...
Um...
I don't want this.
And also, I'm offended that you gave it to me and I don't
want to go into the area anymore.
You tethered to the store like a ghost tethered to a room.
I know!
You're free to go.
Don't look at me like that.
I'm a girl all alone closing this door.
Is this Ghostbusters?
I like to reserve 13 copies of 13 books.
bodies please oh and stiff pc and also some old drama you
have fine tastes all right let's check out what these uh
cursed skews are i don't know i feel like sweaty hot dog
action might be the closest that we've gotten to like a
besides what was it the dessert one like the two girls in a
dessert i'm scared of this one
his step My brother is too big!
Oh, brother!
Okay, maybe I lied.
Maybe this is the club.
And it has four stars.
It's a good critic.
Honestly, should we get it?
It's because it's tall.
Banger.
It is expensive.
That's a good one.
I think...
I think all the girlies will get that.
Whoa!
Wait, nuclear sorcerer warfare.
Is it because it's a rare?
Do we get more money when we rent out rare movies?
Minto, I need more money, proceeds to hold a random guy
hostage.
What?
Who am I holding hostage?
I don't know if mine is shiny.
Let's check.
Nuclear Sorcerer Warfare.
Wait, actually, what was it?
Oh yeah, exactly.
It's the same exact one.
That's so funny.
Okie dokie.
Let's do our movies.
Pumpkin and Moon Base 42.
I'm not holding anyone hostage.
They would like to be here.
Okay.
Alright.
Our horror movies are not doing so hot, huh?
Right now.
Is horror out of sea, is it?
Oh, oops.
Stiff PC came back.
We actually saw the culprit for that.
Just crazy.
Tape on the floor?
Yeah.
But there was a drama.
I mean, we could get another shelf for the dramas, but.
The waitress living on Mars.
I love this one.
She, oh, I'm blocking it.
But when you see it, it looks like...
It looks...
Oh, oops.
T-Rex is back.
Oh my gosh, but I'm getting everything all wrong.
But she looks like the sister from Phineas and Ferb.
Here, I'll show you.
It's a sci-fi.
Doesn't she?
Candace, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Candace.
I'll have two number nines, a number nine larger, a number
six, an extra dip, a number...
Wait, I thought this was a Wendy's.
Sir, this is a Wendy's.
Why are there so many late?
Were these people born yesterday?
They don't... They don't know what a movie places.
Oh my gosh.
The single drama.
This is a Ghostbusters.
Please understand.
Alright.
We can finish up the day.
So probably like two more days.
We didn't do so hot that day.
Probably two more days before we get okay this is sci-fi
this is sci-fi action skews when you got cash and some
random non-adult skews if you like oh okay i have some cash
rooster and sausage we probably do need some more
the fishbowl monster of the sea he's so cute uh why is it in
action.
The rooster?
The only Shinobi.
That one's kind of expensive.
We'll skip.
Sausage of Miami!
Oh, I lost it.
The fairy trapped in the cabin.
It's kind of expensive, though.
Oh, wait.
No, this was a drama.
No!
Jay, what the heck?
Thank you.
I vetoed my entire team at work was laid off back in
January, so I disappeared to grind job apps, but I recently
got hired, so now I can watch this video responsibly again.
Jay!
Congratulations.
I'm so sorry I had to go through that.
And for so long, too.
Congrats!
But also, like, don't send an Akasupa when you just got the
job.
Thank you.
Hey, congrats!
I heard you like fancy movies have this one in my library
let's check it out
grip my pirate why are these so expensive by the tip must be
really rare huh do fairies prefer to be trapped in cabins or
jars what what do you think do you think a fairy prefers to
be trapped in a jar know from experience or anything but i
think a fairy would really hate being in a jar i'm just
saying i don't know from experience and i've never
experienced anything like that before in this life after
life previous life ever but i would just say i think a fairy
would not want to be in a jar bamboo game thank you welcome
back oh is today tuesday nice
oh my god
soon we will be able to get a person
for okay we don't have very much sci-fi though maybe I
should buy a pack mark it 10 random 10 random okay let's see
the dragonbombers uh action horror horror Sunset Godfather
Action Science fiction Cake starship Let's go Science
fiction Astro Golf Marine 3000 Cosmic RV trip With stuffed
toy That sounds terrible Every living thing that can't fit
in a jar Will not know the difference between the jar and
the outside world If you put a stick with a few leaves Okay
I don't know about that one.
Remember brothers, fairy and jar equals full heals.
No!
It's a myth!
Don't buy into it!
Uh, was there?
Oh wait, I forgot to do the returns also.
We might get more sci-fi now.
On full view.
Okay.
I have no more space for drama.
Hello?
You!
Will you be working alone?
What if this is the tape dealer?
No!
What's our code?
Uh...
We'll have...
More T-Rex?
in the afternoon thank you how are they still new okay this
must be a bug but it works for us I don't even mind it
broken no we lost one crazy who broke how could you return
it and it's broken I literally have it on file can't we
charge the oh wait i think we do charge them actually but
they have to be a repeat customer
12 bodies actually no i think it would be 14 bodies because
oops because we added another body count
it's the sticker on the tape it doesn't say new when you
pick it up
It It does say new
It does say new
Forever new I want to be Forever new Do you really want a
new Forever Oops Endeavor Forever Okay nice Alright We're
just missing three now That's not so bad Reserved.
A popular pick, huh?
Well, Rocket Man who followed you home sounds like a good
movie.
Bam, my beat.
Gosh, Dragon Team The Last Hope sounds awesome, though.
And Rooster and Sausage.
13 bodies always comes back.
Alright!
today we're geeking out sci-fi sci-fi meteor shower don't
don't forget it don't get don't get it twisted you gotta
have that you gotta have that movie for the meteor shower
you gotta go to space the meteor shower takes place there oh
yeah everybody's returning their movies and you oh I have no
flyers left
Hold on, I need to give out like five more flyers before I
assist you.
Oh, yes, yes.
Don't go, don't go.
No, please.
My potential customer.
Oh, not Humph.
Not Humph.
No!
Ultraman, the gesture returns.
Wow.
Hello?
Two dollar.
You're free to go.
No hump!
Why do you love so much 13 bodies?
Liam is actually, what if he's the biggest hater?
He wears glasses and doors because he's like, I can't have
them see my actual identity because I'm the one.
I'm the one getting the bodies.
I have Willy Wonka back here.
and and he is breaking them I have a late fee okay then if
you say so I'll be more careful see that's an appropriate
response you take responsibility you say yeah I'm sorry what
Steve I'm stuck babysitting tonight do you have an old movie
to recommend the kids always fall asleep watching boring
classics I'd enjoy a recommendation even more if it was an
action film old action film oh Oh, and it's rare.
Yeah, that guy was a good...
That guy was a good egg.
That guy was a good guy.
Classy fellow.
Hey.
The last movie I returned was pretty bad.
I'm sure no one was waiting for it.
So there's no need to charge me a late fee.
I was waiting for it.
I guess the only one to play I'm the only one to blame, I
guess.
I will pay.
I'm gonna get everybody's money for the layfares.
Yeah!
The Rocket Man had followed you home.
It's a popular one.
50 cent.
You're free to go.
Oh yeah.
Willy Wonka.
And you didn't try out one of our chocolate bars!
What kind of candy man are you?
Can you make bootlegs and rent them out?
That'd be wild.
A new release!
Please take the color violet.
No one's renting it.
He's a fake?
Yeah, exactly.
Wait, I might be out of chocolate.
Oh, you're right.
I'm out of chocolate.
Oh, our thief is Ryan.
Ryan, you, I mean, you're paying for it.
It's not a thief.
It's not stealing.
But you took the last one.
You're free to go?
Yeah, that's what you say when you were...
Right?
We can restock these.
Actually, we can put some of these up, too.
And then we can...
Crunch Zilla.
Woo!
Everybody went to Crunch Zilla.
everybody want a cringy little and uh super chips super
chips oh they cost so little and they sell for so much our
profit margins through the roof baby yeah you're i see you
looking in here i see you curious about me yeah oh yeah i
see i'll get you as soon as you walk by Oh.
Stonks.
Yeah, they're super chips.
You were great.
Do we have more sci-fi movies?
I guess so.
Because I see that guy right there holding up.
Yeah.
You were nervous.
You were like, do I belong in there?
I don't know anything about movies.
Do I even Do I even deserve to go into the movie store?
Let me tell you.
Everyone of all kinds is deserving.
Everybody.
We take anybody at the movie store.
I've seen it all.
I've seen Anthony get stiff PC along with retirement with my
gargoyle.
And you know what?
I'm not judging.
Movies for everybody.
You're free to go.
The angry trooper.
What the?
You were just trying to break a bill, weren't you?
Why are you upset?
Are you okay?
What's wrong?
A sad drama.
Um...
The mammal.
A true burden.
There you go.
What'd you get?
The yacht through space.
snacks are the biggest upsell item in basically any business
gas stations don't make money off of the gas really reading
a webtoon project mars with the main character being a teal
colored alien named mint it always makes me think of you
that's like basically me we'll put some more chips wait
nobody's buying the chips though kind of nervous hmm hmm I'm
kind of nervous.
Oh, please.
I might be an alien.
Alien.
What does the alien?
One moment, please.
Probably should have spent my time getting more people to
come in here.
We have made a good amount of money today, though.
Oh, you're free to go.
I still feel like the sensitivity on this is a little
craziness but hey hey hey don't look away don't look this
way look no what do you mean hmm what are we hating for what
are we hating for staff soon yeah wait you want one no staff
soon The sensitivity is adjustable.
I might turn it down because I feel like I'm giving you guys
whiplash.
If anything.
I'm like whipping around.
Like I'm locked in.
I'm doing the work.
Sandrine.
Interesting name.
Here let me uh let me fix it a little bit.
Options.
We'll go down to like 0.4 maybe.
It's a bit better.
Yeah, actually, that's much better.
Whoa, busy night, huh?
Yeah, of course.
Binary is right.
In addition, the most profitable snack item is soda.
Gallons of soda cost cents to produce.
So the profit margins are insane for businesses.
So I do need more snacks.
I don't know, though.
I think I'm making a profit from my movies.
Oh, oops.
Maybe that's what makes this a little unrealistic, huh?
I do have a soda machine.
Oh, slushy machine.
We'll have cotton candy and popcorn.
Any second now.
Come on.
And it is reserved.
Does it look a little better for you guys?
I hope so.
Sorry I was playing on psycho mode.
before.
Like, crazy fast.
Cotton candy would be really cheap, too.
It's just sugar, no?
You watch this movie, it will give you a full heal.
Oh.
Fairy in a vial!
Oh!
It is science fiction.
We'll buy it.
I'm a fairy in a vial.
You gotta rub me the right way.
if you are I'm a fairy in the fire
reserved skull brain implants is really popular actually
well it won't let me see like how many times it's been
rented out but it's been rented out a number of times at
this point.
Everyone I'm a
saucy snake delivery.
Not much of our adult went this time though.
Two ladies for one dessert.
Is, wait let's put only two times.
Nobody wants a gun machine oiled up.
I'm sorry.
Literally no one asked for this.
Okay.
Nobody asked for this.
Okay, let's sleep.
$254?
Yes!
Are we gonna hire staff?
It's huge.
It's actually groundbreaking.
Oh my gosh, grow your team.
Use the staff book to hire and manage your employees new
applicants with different gameplay traits appear every day
all right we got gabrielle we got ryan lucas is too slow
gabrielle's oh wait they have traits too runner walk walk
speed never falls asleep at work does not take a bathroom
breaks but he's average on both things
here too slow yeah but he well he's not that much cheaper
he's only $10 cheaper.
I think Ryan might be our bet.
Because I didn't realize.
I guess they'll sleep.
So we need to...
He won't take a bathroom break either.
This guy is made of steel.
Let's hire Ryan.
Hire your first employee.
Well, we're going to put him...
Oh.
Hello.
Scared me.
Is that our guy?
Oh, he is so stoked.
He's like, I got my first job at the Mario store!
Hi, Ryan!
Morning.
I'm still waking up.
I need to punch in first.
I'm not working for free.
You're so right, Ryan.
I'm so sorry.
Yep.
Hey, boss.
a $19 salary bump.
My rent's going up next month and I need the money.
Ryan, you just got here.
No!
It was worth a try.
Oh my god!
I don't think I like Ryan very much.
A scary sailor.
Ryan!
You have not worked.
Literally, you just punched in.
You just punched in.
Uh...
What's 10% of resigning?
I am firing you.
Let's assign to checkout.
You'll be our checkout guy.
So I will work the return desk while he does checkout.
And then that means I can get more people in and all too,
you know?
Oh no, it's finally!
It's finally not a new release.
Oh, no.
No, no.
Uh-oh.
I wonder he has a steel bladder.
He's real ballsy if he asks that day one.
I missed the tape dealer last night.
No!
Oh wait, we have a new movie coming tomorrow though.
We'll be able to fill this back up.
But all of these...
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Someone said we get a clearance, I remember.
Someone said we get a clearance, uh...
Bin, eventually.
We'll be able to sell them off, probably.
How you doing, Ryan?
The slow...
Never mind, keep working.
The slow turn as he's like shaking.
Are you okay, Ryan?
Are you okay?
All the Ryan's in the chat right now being like, she's
talking to me!
Ryan gives me the creeps.
He's just a newbie.
It's his first day.
It's him having to hold his pee.
Broken knot to steal Duchess on patrol.
Actually, didn't know that.
We had that one.
You could also open up shop.
We'll get all of our stuff taken care of.
this handled first.
Luckily the time does not pass while we're doing this stuff.
So it's honestly pretty nice because we can just like oh
wait we can just do everything how we need to and then open
up when we're nice and clean and uh alright.
Alright we need some more we need some more movies I think.
thinks we need some more movies let's do a random oh we
could do five 20 random movies wait this one robo cowboy
supercharge let's buy that it looks pretty good a killer
bubble gum in our house the cauldron a true burden power man
and troll doll robots sign me up Soldier.
Nuclear voodoo doll warfare.
Milk carton and Moonbase 42.
Climbing book mountain.
Stranger in a vile.
Blazing officer.
Where cookies is fall?
I don't know if there should be a apostrophe there.
The doghouse computer virus.
The depressed performer.
Power man and troll.
Let's get it.
Yeah, let's get it.
Power Man Entrol.
The Beast Labyrinth.
The Ninja Mammoth.
Alright, that's a couple good ones we got.
I'm worried for the 20 randoms because like what if we get a
bunch of drama?
I guess I could always just buy another... I mean I should
buy another shelf.
You were paying Ryan $2.75 an hour and can't give him a
raise smh my streamer to stingy what was the average pay in
the united states in 1990 whatever this was to my silliest
minke i would like to say thank you because you i was able
to keep smiling after losing somebody important to me in my
school so keeping the afterlife silliest made error thank
you thank you five dollars it wasn't two dollars ryan asked
for a 19 raise you guys if he's getting two dollars an hour
he asked for a 19 raise it's kind of insane don't look at me
though I think Ryan was just checking me out.
He says, damn right I was.
All right, Ryan.
Do good out there.
Oh my gosh, so many people.
Don't leave.
Oh.
I rented a few movies from you, and one of them feels cheap.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Whatever.
I'm too busy.
Hey.
Don't leave.
No.
Leave me alone.
Yeah, you'll come by.
Yes.
Pay him an exposure.
Ryan is out here trying to...
He's trying to be...
He's in, like, la-la land.
You know, he's trying to be a famous actor.
He's like, if I work at a movie store, maybe I'll be
inspired to act.
Hello.
Why is everybody shaking?
Why are you all afraid of me?
Good job, Ryan.
He's taking...
Oh, look at him go.
Look at him go.
I'm so proud of him.
Proud of my little Ryan.
Oh, wait.
Let's put that on the top shelf.
As a Ryan, I currently feel called out.
As you should.
Reserved.
Which one?
This is a hot dog.
Sausage and moon base.
They do grow up so fast.
I mean, we should have some 13 bodies in here in general,
right?
So...
Our...
Oops.
Our adult section is almost full.
Craziness.
A drama.
Hmm.
You need to pay!
Rules of rules!
She paid!
Oh my gosh.
Customers, customers, customers.
Potential customers, please.
Come to my...
Yes!
Oh!
Oh my god!
We got every single person!
Yes!
Everybody, come on!
Come on!
The video store is just...
It's just a smaller circus!
It's so entertaining for everyone!
Yes!
Everybody wants to rent movies!
Okay.
Grumpy pants.
I hope Ryan doesn't expect to get...
Oh my god.
I hope he doesn't expect to get a lunch break though, you
know?
A little worried about that.
Circus of values.
I was gonna play Bioshock today.
I was gonna try and finish it.
but I just didn't have it in me to do a long stream.
So, the plan is to finish Bioshock tomorrow.
Please forgive me.
This is the smallest bill I have.
Do they say stuff to you like that?
Sometimes.
Look, we're getting so many people to come in.
Oh, wait.
You.
I miss you.
You?
Wait.
Don't go, huh?
But yeah, I do want to finish Bioshock tomorrow, so...
Hmm...
Why is everybody so grumpy?
What the?
The king's famous pie.
What is it doing out here?
Why is the king's famous pie?
Who stole from my store?
Guys, we're making so much money.
Actually, though.
Wait, this is kind of insane.
Ryan is my good luck charm.
I love you, Ryan!
I'll never abandon you.
I'll never fire you.
Maybe.
Don't leave, don't leave, don't leave, don't leave.
Yes.
Oh my god!
Humph, humph.
Too many humphsons.
And it's only 5 p.m.
Where are the money bags?
Soon customers.
Yeah, he's like, I'm going to go get a movie.
Hopefully they have a tutorial on how to grow hair.
There you go, ma'am.
Yeah.
Nah, it's okay.
He looks good, bald.
Oh.
nobody is returning anything though it's kind of crazy come
on Ryan don't just stand there yeah sorry oh you bought
something hello customer yeah YouTube before YouTube you
know you had to you had to go to Blockbuster and ask them
How do I grow hair?
How do I fix my car?
What if they had, like, blockbusters of tutorials?
That'd be kind of crazy, though.
You know?
DIY videos?
No one's returned anything.
But we're getting so many more people in this.
know.
It's kind of insane.
I think they had a section like that.
No way!
You had almanacs instead.
Oh, man.
I have to read.
I'm a visual learner.
What if I need someone telling me step-by-step direction?
No thanks.
I'm running late.
Well, you'll be back, right?
You'll try another time.
Ryan doesn't need a bathroom break Yeah, this is
pre-YouTube, you guys We need the DIY section We need the
How do I fix When my washing machine Starts overflowing And
throwing up this error sign What do I do, DVD?
We need that
Come on, dude!
My new releases are all gone.
I remember most tutorial videos back in the day being about
doing magic or hypnosis or how to be a clown or how to get
revenge.
Hello.
Cake Starship.
There you go.
What about...
What about Undead Barrow?
You want that too?
Sweet, sweet.
I think there were more...
Okay, is this where tapes...
Oh, if I throw tapes on the ground, they spawn here.
Oh, I have...
Oh, my God.
Someone keeps moving them into a pile outside.
Oh, we just had that.
There was a dime stuck in some mechanism in your...
In your, uh...
Washing machine?
No!
Look, we're done with the return desk.
We are almost at $600.
Nice.
Good job, Ryan.
High five for your first day.
Did he just shake his head at me?
Okay.
A little aggressive.
I don't think...
Ryan's like, this is just a job.
We are not friends.
I'm going to be one of those toxic work environments that's
like, we're a family.
And you'd do anything for the family, right?
You would not even take a bath break.
I mean, a bathroom break or a lunch break or anything.
Only seven in snacks.
Our profits on snacks are going way, way down.
Wow, why don't people want chips, huh?
The static haunting!
Oh, yeah.
Wait, is it a Tuesday?
It's a Thursday!
Oh, yeah, baby.
Wait, I have to order five or more copies.
They're here.
Press play if you dare.
But it is a Tuesday.
Right now, when I'm streaming.
We'll get, like, eight?
I think that's a good amount.
Maybe.
We also...
Oh, hello, Ron.
We gotta move our 13 bucks.
Let's move it.
We'll just have it like a display right here, right?
Oh, oh, this is, this faces out.
Wait, oh, like that.
There we go.
Why the horror?
Can we get, oh, we did level up.
Let's see what new decorations we can get.
Door map.
Oh, a jack-o'-lantern.
Oh, movie display.
Yes.
Please tell me you will have a copy of Who Ordered the Hot
T-Rex.
Reserve it for me.
I need to see that movie.
Guys, I can smell the desperation.
Fun fact, a common term for a family that you work for slash
is in is a mafia.
Guys, who ordered the Hot T-Rex?
This movie has been rented seven times.
I think we're on, like, day nine or something.
I think we are on day nine of...
Of owning our store.
Having it open.
Okay.
That's kind of insane.
That's kind of crazy.
Hot T-Rex sells.
Truly.
I get it, though.
Okay.
I came by the other day and I was wondering, why is the
horror section so small?
Any chance you can order more variety?
Is it small?
Yes.
Oh, I got a shiny.
Let's get two more.
New.
Boy.
Okay, I can't.
The static haunting.
Okay.
I forgot that they were shelves of, you know...
of, uh, five.
Ooh!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Let's get some more decorations for the wall.
In general, actually, we have, like...
Oh, we can get balloons!
And small neon signs.
Neon signs.
A coffin!
Sorry, I got a little overboard.
Jackalanturn.
Is it?
What's the season here?
Oh, it looks so good!
Here's the $5 is agreed upon for saying I love you.
Us Ryan's.
Now accept our afterlife with open arms.
Static Haunting was my first new release.
Glad you finally got it.
Oh, nice!
Thank you for more skews.
Intergalactic Bandit.
Science fiction will take it.
Oh, so even the...
Bloody ghost!
A British ghost!
They did ask for more horror, so...
Um...
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
But, uh...
Yeah.
we're gonna decorate the place it's gonna look real nice
where people will find it very appetizing to come in here
all right we'll put okay hold on we'll move you maybe this
is just not a good place to have it maybe maybe it's got to
be more out out and about right maybe oh i can change this
exciting oh i like this oh wait we can put it you guys we
can put in a skew and give any movie oh my god wait this is
huge wait this is huge
put up hot to your you're i you read my mind you literally
read my mind what is the skew for the hot t-rex
how can i close inspect how can i tell how can i know oh
wait six okay can someone get this six nine three six two
one eight three six nine oh vivicourt thanks for the five
gifted oh oops one second one second six nine three six two
one eight three thank you yes oh my bad
we do of course we do and we also just got a bunch more in
so everybody's
returning it all at once yeah we have many copies maybe it
should have done the uh shiny one but it's kind of oh dang
it it's kind of random too like it doesn't like
it kind of just picks one off the shelf right
Is that the mammal burden?
How you got your sunglasses on?
Are you trying to be a cool dude?
Because it's working.
So he returned the gargoyle.
Did he return the naughty film too?
We shall see.
Reserved.
Oh, everything is reserved.
Folly, thank you so much for the pink!
Sorry I'm late.
Don't apologize.
I had to be present at some point.
seminar, but now I'm home and ready to relax with my Oshi
and her freaky ways.
Why would you apologize?
Seminar is important.
Thank you so much for the pick.
Thank you.
Oh, look.
We got intergalactic bandit and then robo-cowboy
supercharged.
Yes, the waitress living on Mars.
She's back, baby.
That's my waitress.
Nope.
That's my waitress living on Mars.
I wonder do more people start coming in if you like have
more variety of movies.
So maybe we should get like another random movie thing.
We'll do that.
We'll get another random movie thing.
We will, um, I gotta place my coffin.
We'll get another thing for drama.
And that should be good.
Sort of.
Okay.
Let's put this here.
Can I?
There we go.
Default text.
We'll move that.
Like here.
Yeah, looks good.
Wait, I'm calling to reserve a movie.
Oh wait, what was the title again?
Hmm.
I totally forgot.
Is it okay to call back when I remember?
Yeah!
We have more things.
I got some balloons.
Kick-ass balloons.
Holy.
That kind of creeping me out.
Oh, we got a heart.
Wait, we could put it.
Oh, yeah.
What does the shiny signify?
Do they rent for higher money?
Do they just look cool?
You got, like, half a shelf worth it.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what they do, to be honest.
Wait.
Oh, the car's last heartbeat.
That's so good.
The guitar's last heartbeat.
I thought it said Eurobeat.
That's how I was like, the car's last Eurobeat.
The pixie monster of the sea.
Dentist on top of the world.
Explosive teddy bear.
fair the sculpture's perfect sunset which came first all
right let's do 10 random movies oh wait i don't think i can
buy a shelf now i cannot okay we'll have to save up for that
what do we got any shinies no
uh oh i might be out of space for a lot of stuff sci-fi oh
good They gave me a bunch of sci-fi in action.
The fighting fish!
Hag on death row.
Where I wish Mitara would be every day.
Alright!
Let's open up, baby!
Come on!
What do you mean?
Why?
You're the weirdo that is that is walking without an
umbrella what
are you yeah you you want a flyer you want a flyer yeah yeah
she says wait he's on checkout right yeah he's just kind of
standing there potential customer okay all right
oh let's go brain implants let's go
Oh, thank you for telling me that I missed two super chats,
but please don't spam.
Sorry that I missed them.
I'm so sorry.
Ma'am, where do you keep the gummy bears?
Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Sometimes the game is a little demanding of my attention.
Oh, good.
He got the drink order right and everything.
Oh good, and he's making them pay!
Yeah, make them pay!
Make them pay!
Oh, already on your way!
I like how he goes, oh!
You look like a customer.
Wow!
Oh yeah, she says.
Why don't you like it?
I don't have time for this.
Rude.
Hmm.
Oh.
Yacht through space Everyone's coming I want to know who's
getting the T-Rex Yeah, everybody's wet The movies are wet
Like everything's going to come back Soggy and broken Ooh
Ooh Yes What about you?
I'm running late Hmm Oh we have more movies even Sorry,
everybody.
We'll keep our shelves nice and full.
Yeah.
Lots of movies.
It's so quiet.
All the adult movies.
That thing was almost, you guys.
That shelf was like basically full.
That's insane.
Wait.
All the adult movies are gone.
This town!
I swear.
This town is...
they have no shame they have no shame i mean i'm here for it
she's cornering the market i i've got it i've got it the
freaks came out again where is everybody where are you is
this a no you you you you oh wait wait wait wait don't leave
Don't leave!
No!
Oh, sorry.
There you go.
Please say yes.
No!
He hates movies, which means he hates me.
Oh.
How was the video?
Ooh.
More stuff.
getting returned oh and he's gonna get another movie he
loves us he loves us he loves us oh it's did you get the
time I think he got the T-Rex it's like so wholesome I'm
sorry I doubted you you got the color finally here I am the
It's like the exact opposite.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yes!
Get chips!
Get the super chips.
They're so good.
Yeah.
Poor guy getting judged.
It's not that I'm trying to judge him.
It's just, you know.
Okay.
We buy this.
Now we can put up more...
We can put up all of these bad boys.
Oh.
Can I put up all of these bad boys?
Uh oh, oh, my hands are full.
They're not.
Whoa, this is really tall.
I think there was more behind here.
Uh, actually we need to make it blue?
Yeah.
Yes.
It's a corner.
It's a corner shelf.
It looks good.
Trust.
X-ray, welcome back!
I noticed a lack of Japanese animation movies, also known as
anime.
Michael!
It's niche stuff, but it will guarantee a customer
demographic.
I don't need your nerd movies.
Okay, we gotta get more people in.
Please.
Yes, please, please.
Hmm.
We got to get more people in.
It's almost 8 p.m.
We got to have enough money for the dealer.
Tonight is the dealer.
Yes, yes, yes.
The term is Japanimation.
Not interested.
Please.
Okay, what area did we open up shop because sirens are going
crazy?
Hmm.
Please!
I'll have a...
Oh, copper kettle.
I'll have...
I'll have anime tomorrow.
I prefer a good book over a movie.
What?
You think you're better than us?
I'm a visual person.
You just be...
It's not everybody can picture things in their heads, you
know.
Oh my gosh, the rain is coming down.
Can you imagine how I look?
I'm like, I'm like soaked to the bone and I'm just chasing
these people being like, please come to my...
Come to my video store, please!
I'm drenched the...
Uh-oh, wait, do we have the color violet?
Uh-oh.
Broken and it's a shiny!
No.
Hmm.
Wait, who's...
Rules are rules, yeah, yeah.
Don't give my guy a hard time.
Uh-oh, we don't have it.
I'm sorry.
All our sci-fi movies are gone!
Whoa.
No wonder we got so many more in.
Horror is not doing so well, though.
If the hot T-Rex ever comes broken, I will cry.
Me too.
That would be the most unfortunate thing.
Okay.
I will cry.
Cost for breaking shinies is blood.
The atonal dissection is completely empty.
Don't worry, guys.
We restock immediately.
We're so on the ball.
We're so...
Look, everything is...
Things are, like, really moving now.
It's kind of awesome.
Maybe we tried renting in a video store.
yeah back when the video stores you know maybe the smiley
faces would be good for when we get comedy i have them right
next to horror it's kind of funny oopsie good job today ryan
good job today all the new releases are gone all right it is
raining out here the bathroom is still just there what do we
got the hot dog my fantasy i
wasn't sold on rhyme when he asked for a 19 raise yeah he
really redeemed himself he really redeemed himself ninja
clairvoyant dr lane's chosen yacht also tobacco in my mouth
it's just called smoking a best seller in the underground
market huh
Hot dog My
fantasy They never invented smoking in this universe Yeah
the chew I know okay I understand not smoking on a plane
obviously But you know how they're like no chewing tobacco
on planes Why I don't get They're like no smoking or chewing
tobacco When you like take off But I don't really understand
like I mean, it's...
Because it's stinky.
Oh, you have to spit it out!
Oh!
Oh, you think people were like spitting it in the toilet or
something?
Oh, people would spit on the...
Ew!
Oh, my gosh.
Icky.
Oh, we got raided.
Thank you!
Sorry I didn't see who raided.
Thank you so much.
Welcome to our humble establishment.
must make a sign for the hot dog fantasy.
We'll do a small frame because we're running out of money.
Or I'm trying to conserve money.
Our adult section is looking great.
This is so awesome.
Tomb Velocity, get out of here.
Wait, I need the skill.
699-529-53.
69952.
6...
69952...953?
Was that it?
Yes!
Hot dog, my fantasy.
Oh, let's change how it looks too.
Oh, I cannot.
Just kidding.
It still looks great.
Still looks great.
Total $329.
Nice.
Alright.
Who the hell is?
Oh, it's Friday the 13th!
Ew!
Oh!
Oh, it's only you.
Ding!
Good morning!
Hey!
Jason?
He's just chilling outside like a mascot.
Can I start giving these out?
Oh, I can.
Hmm.
There's so many people.
Let's open this door.
Oh, wait.
I need to do this.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
We need to...
Oh, I restocked.
Or...
Ryan, I'm sorry.
I need you up here, please.
Ryan.
Oh, he's so good.
Don't put the color violet.
on the adult side.
Oh my god, he scared me.
Bye.
One second.
Thanks for being my cute ghost, Oshi.
My birthday is tomorrow.
Happy birthday, Holly!
Happy birthday!
Aw.
Thank you for the super time!
Oops.
I'd like to rent hot dog my fantasy, please.
It's a...
high demander it's a hot oh gosh there's so many people
coming in holy cow okay hello computer computer virus the
computer computer virus i got it right here for you yes
jason oh my gosh i should have done this before i'm such an
idiot i'm such an idiot you guys i just opened this door
immediately.
I didn't do any of the work.
Ah!
Oh, wait.
I've meant to put this on the top.
That's fine.
Uh.
Yes.
Oops.
Come on.
That went there.
Oops.
There we go.
Alright.
Everything's going well.
Don't forget to rewind your DVDs.
I know.
Oh.
Was that you?
Did you not rewind?
I see you there.
I see you.
All right.
More horror is stalked, everybody.
Wait, what was for Friday the 13th?
You know, I didn't even check.
50% horror movie rentals.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Perfect.
Um...
Um, one second.
Can't you say hi?
Can't you say excuse me?
That's what y'all you gotta say.
What?
Psycho killer foot?
Yes.
For you.
Horror.
Oh my gosh, there's so many movies.
I was a fool.
hire a second person to handle this part.
And then what would I do?
I would just be outside like a maniac passing out flyers.
We might be able to afford a second person, right?
Oh, of course I picked the one movie that's also shiny.
Oh, you need to level up.
No!
The game is sabotaging me.
We will buy some more movies, though.
I feel like maybe I...
Oops.
Oh, who got the gumball?
I feel like maybe I...
Can...
Hey.
I want to...
The client is asking to see a manager!
I was gonna say about the shelves because some of the
shelves are, you know.
The last movie I returned was bad anyway.
Who cares if it's broken now?
with you all day a good movie science fiction we got that
for sure good movie bad movie good movie science fiction
what a jerk I know right to say my movie was bad we're gonna
ban that guy but he at least paid one second one second one
second one second oh my gosh there's the movies don't stop
you guys they never end i'm suffering from success at the
moment i think what are you contemplating huh is this a
video store yeah i actually joined the no job squad today no
no tomorrow the leasing office is wanting to show my
apartment a potential tenant I leave my dojins out and dirty
clothes on the floor?
Yeah.
Aww.
Oh.
That guy didn't seem very thrilled about it, though.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Drama, that's bad.
Surely.
Yeah.
This one.
The T-Rex is back.
T-Rex is back.
We'll do saucy snake.
This one.
Okay, nice.
We finally caught up.
No, we didn't.
We finally...
You!
You didn't rewind!
I saw!
I hope you guys are okay.
Whoa!
So many people.
Action.
Well, in the meantime, while you're searching for no job,
I'll be around.
streaming so you know you can just come watch hello keep
your company you know no please my customers your customer
yeah yeah oh man you really have to get through the movies
like to...
At the beginning of the day, or else it's craziness.
Or else it's actual craziness.
Yeah!
Ooh!
Is Mask Guy a customer?
I don't think so.
Oh, oh, sorry.
He speaks!
He went...
Oh, this guy looks like he's having a bad day.
What if you get the t-rex yeah exactly that guy's gonna go
get the hot t-rex it's still it's still who ordered a hot
t-rex that guy please fix my leaky heirloom oh my gosh we
have it
yeah Jason shows up on Friday the 13th it's so cute waited
bathroom
Nuclear Sorcerer.
All of our snacks are almost gone, you guys!
Oh, yeah!
All of our snacks are...
Oh, we're selling, we're selling.
Horror movie, that's bad.
Alright.
I got you.
I mean, that's like 99% of them, maybe.
It's like the easiest genre to...
You know?
I don't rewind.
What are you gonna do?
Revoke my membership?
I might spit in your popcorn.
Err.
Thomas.
With your fixing the leaky heirloom, huh?
There you go, buddy.
Yeah.
I know it's awesome.
I know.
He has a great taste.
Oh.
Did I run into you or something?
Stop that!
Oh.
What did I do?
Wait, I'm actually confused.
Oh, it's midnight.
No!
For free?
I'm gonna watch you.
Watch what you're doing, please.
I like how he carries it in the little basket.
That's so cute.
And Thomas is getting a slushy to go.
Don't look at me so excited.
My man's cheesing.
He's so ready for the movie.
Magic of VHS Rental.
Watching a movie that has a bit of a looty scene and the
tracking is all screwed up from people watching that part
over and over.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait, you could do that?
We're gonna get chairs and stuff soon.
That's so exciting.
Equipment.
Oh, I have a TV!
What is that?
What's this do?
The clearance bundle.
The tape getting worn out.
Oh, I wanted to buy some more movies.
not new um movie bundle the devil's monkey we can't we
shouldn't do so much more though so much more horror though
right now astro golf do do do astro golf i am astro golf
astro golf explosive zilla is insane let's buy that The
foot, my only friend.
What about that?
The doghouse gang assault.
Checkmate.
Gas mask.
The psychotic yacht.
The fishbowl star cup.
The hot dog body snatchers!
Anything with a hot dog.
Maybe we should...
The offering of the...
milk carton.
We should have like a theme, right?
Not a sussy part, but my VHS copy of Disney's Hercules got
rewound and watched so much.
My copy is now permanently messed up and the music is out of
tune.
It's like it's old bad creepypasta.
Wait, that's so funny.
I didn't know that could happen.
I had no idea.
Let's grab like all of the... We got the hot dog body
snatchers.
Rocket!
dinosaur.
Mammoth and moon base 42.
Yacht power up.
Shipmate.
Hacker.
Had some Rugrats VHS that would randomly fast forward.
That's creepy.
Oh, we got a lot of horror.
Octopus.
You will die.
The demented ape.
Satan and his hot dog.
The deadly lady.
The love seat has risen.
The dead.
You love the balloons?
I'm glad I did too.
I like them quite a bit.
We left the bear behind.
That's so sad.
Knockout pixie.
Ponds and cask.
Inheriting the organ.
The infection walks alone.
A foot my only friend.
Explosive Zilla.
Oh, my bad.
Explosive book.
Alright.
Good job today, Ryan.
We have now established that Minto didn't exist until DVDs
did.
Unless she was one of those fancy people with laser discs.
No.
That's a lot of kissing.
Okay, we got romance.
La, la, la, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a,
a, a, a, oh, la, la, we just unlocked romance.
Do I have enough to, like, get more shelves?
We'll do two of the...
I think it's this one, right?
Four row?
Wait, let's go count.
Hi, Ryan.
One, two, three.
Yeah, four.
We'll get two four rows.
Oh, yeah, we'll get two of them.
And we'll set it up exactly as these ones are.
can I make these pink yeah power up I think we just got that
in
do you watch romance films I don't not watch romance films
but like I definitely would not choose a rom-com or anything
as my movie of choice you know we can't do red What if we do
poopy brown?
I don't know.
We could...
Where's the pink?
No pink?
None.
Does
that expansion poster across from the computer?
Oh yeah, let's see how much that is, right?
Uh, this one.
Wait.
Not this one.
Where?
Over the computer?
Oh.
Wait, where is...
Expansion?
Wait, I'm washed?
I wonder if there's some tapes out here.
Left of doorway.
Okay, there are none.
Oh!
Whoa, it's expensive.
Yeah, like, I guess I would have to get A or B.
I guess we would get B.
Once we can afford it.
So we just basically need to save up for it.
I think we can do that.
Let's go with red.
It's the closest to pink.
It's the closest.
Also...
Ooh, I like that.
On everything.
Put it on and off.
Change it all.
It looks so like old VHS, right?
Can I make my snacks pretty?
No.
Alright.
Oops.
Let's go.
movies.
Yeah, my free movies.
Romance SKUs!
Buy at your caution.
What does that mean?
Oh, some Romance SKUs!
Oh, thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Time with the dinosaur!
I have to.
Even though it was kind of expensive.
My ghosts only regret.
This one's cheap.
Buy it.
Uh...
Wait, uh-oh.
Three, three, nine, two, three, nine, two.
Marrying my explosive.
A little pricey.
All I need is my zombie.
That was all so good.
One moment.
Oh, man, you also...
Oh, my gosh.
Time traveling fetus.
You also said...
Date night with my car.
It's so expensive, though.
Oh, oops.
Six, three.
Closer to my dragon!
Retirement with my gargoyle.
Right there in the middle of the shelf.
Ready for ya.
Alright, let's get our free movies!
Oh, frying pan ghost story!
Oh, it's a horror though.
The dentist romantic story.
Oh my gosh, this guy again.
Ultraman, the tobacco returns.
It's a dragon, it says dragon, but it's a T-Rex.
We just say, oh, it's dragon bombers.
We just pretend.
The Light Keeper's hot dog.
What do you think about the hot dog?
Secrets of the Forbidden Snake.
Scary music flick.
The Angry Teacher.
Oh, wait, did I get my free ones?
I got too busy looking at everything else.
I got
it my ghost wait did I get did I buy this I can't remember
all I need is my stuff toy fairy between our hearts love as
light as the spirit oh that's a drama our lord's first date
a letter to my breakfast our pot plants first date closer to
my dragon hot dog very good very good
quiet time with the dinosaur kissing my organ in the sky a
heart's true lover she played as the doctor waited oh my
gosh you guys we just got your lie in april
Yeah, we're like, we specialize in dinosaur and hot dog
movies.
We got actually your lie in April here in store.
Come to Ghostbusters.
You were looking for Japanimation now, weren't you?
Young fella.
I've got all the Japanimation you could ask for.
That was close.
All right, we need our static haunting movies back.
I feel like people have been hoarding those and not bringing
them back.
What's up with that?
It is April already.
It's kind of crazy.
live action anime was there a live action for for that movie
or for that anime I feel like your line April would be a
super easy one to make a live action for any like slice of
life you know oh thank goodness you're there for Shigatsu
yeah yeah yeah Shigatsu is it Kimi no so I think so it feels
like there would be right if you guys want like a sad drama
i think we kind of talked about it yesterday how like if
you've watched um but how like some japanese endings are
very like bittersweet or open-ended or just not all so happy
right but um one liter of tears oh my god one liter of tears
is one of those like It's based on a true story.
But it's one of those that you're like, It's starting to get
confusing.
In what order should I watch the hot dog series?
Honestly, they're episodic.
You can take the hot dog at any time.
You're okay, you're okay.
Snow is icy!
Welcome back, thank you!
With a name like that, I believe it.
I know.
It's so sad.
One liter of tears.
Hot dog by fantasy.
Too good.
Alright.
Shelves are stocked almost.
We'll do some more.
Chippies.
What else can we do?
Freddy's!
Disco Kong.
Kara.
Caramel popcorn.
Dino gummies.
What do we have, Crunchyzilla?
I think, well, like I said, we'll keep to the Dino theme and
everything.
Our little place is filling up, you guys.
I'm proud of us.
Oh, we can buy a ceiling sign!
That's so fun.
I don't know what this is, but...
Um Oh Because we got our UFO Oh let's move the UFO Right New
release maybe Oh Move the UFO to like closer to sci-fi Yeah
Ryan's the goal Ryan You're alright Okay today is saturday
we might get a million people coming in it's the weekend
weekend and what is that we'll come back
doors are open oh i don't know i prefer watching a movie on
a friday is that strange seems like the traditional time to
watch the movie oh thank you all for returning your movies
but i really need like new customers and money thank you
okay okay slam jam no not for me yee how what did you want
retirement with my gargoyle a classic
Uh oh.
Things are starting to come in.
Friday makes the end of the work week.
It's not that strange.
Right.
It just feels right.
I guess it's also because like...
Hmm.
When, you know...
You're in school.
You sometimes watch movies on Fridays in class.
And just makes you be like, yeah.
Want to watch a movie?
On a Friday.
Let's go put this in the pile.
The rocket man that follows you home.
Vengeful ghost.
More 13 bodies.
Wait.
Whoa.
This line is getting a little crazy.
Yacht power up.
He's like, come on, bud.
What are you staring at?
Ooh.
Pass.
Why pass?
Will Ryan also restock the movies if he's on return?
I think so.
Oh, we got more people coming in.
Yeah, wow.
I know it's awesome.
Yeah, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
He does move a little slow.
Actually, I think it said he was average.
How dare you insult his capabilities?
Calling him slow.
He's average.
They, when you got Metal Gear, they rubber band the case.
That's so fun!
Color violet.
Did you reserve it?
Yes, you did.
Oh.
I don't like the way he's staring at me while he's handing
him money.
What do I have to do with your purchase, huh?
Reserved.
Alright.
Anybody want more?
Sci-fi!
Drama.
Horror.
Action.
Sci-fi.
Let's put this back there.
Oh, yeah, there, there.
Okay.
Stiff PC!
Haven't seen you in so long!
Oops.
Explosive Zilla!
Nobody grabbing, nobody grabbing.
What did you get?
This is dessert's wrong number?
What's cope?
Oh my god, there's so many people.
Please come.
No!
So close!
Please come.
Please come to my store.
What'd you get?
The color violet.
Do you have a copy?
Yes, I do.
Just, why don't you use your eyes, buddy?
I don't have time for you.
Did you reserve something?
Wow.
She's huge.
Holy cow.
You're like the tallest lady I've ever seen.
Whoa!
She's looking at me!
She's ginormous.
Her.
I think all those people already bought stuff.
Is the sun coming out or not?
I'm confused.
It seems like it wants to.
Hello?
Explosive Zilla?
Yes, you did.
Ooh, is coming for their pink neon cowboy.
How is it rude?
It's a compliment.
Look at her!
She's so tall!
It's a compliment.
There was a whole movie about it.
Oh, you got the pink neon cowboy.
Yeah, yeah.
Finally.
Looks like daily sea weather.
Yeah.
This is...
Goodbye.
Goodbye, my queen.
I found him!
Wilde.
oh I'm running late okay understandable I guess what a woman
this will turn your day upside down yeah exactly you were
walking around you were so upset you're like really
spaghetti upsetting spaghetti not just spaghetti sorry drama
okay you can you not like go just pick something off the
shelf man
hmm all right yes oh we got some more adult movies back in
sci-fi lovers rejoice
oops oops
uh what did i drop this one you Sorry, excuse me.
Oh no, we're out of space!
Get it?
It's sci-fi.
We're actually in space.
Oh, oops.
I wonder what Waldo's renting.
What is that guy into?
Stealth movies, I think.
Maybe?
Or something?
Yeah, grab a sci-fi.
Okay.
Look at this, look at this impeccable service.
Immediate restock.
The born identity.
Uh, uh, master of disguise.
Um.
Invasive bull!
That's okay, I didn't care so much about that one, actually.
Very good.
Carmen San Diego?
Oh yeah.
Oh, that's a good one.
Hiya.
Hello.
One second.
Please.
All right.
We could restock.
This is peak.
Oh, shoot.
Science fiction!
Wow.
Do you like the yacht in space?
You just dropped off the bubble gum.
The gum oiled up machine.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
It's midnight and we still have a line.
This is crazy.
You can put holographic cassettes in a display case.
Oh, is that what that's for?
But, do we not get more money for...
For...
Renting them?
Is there really no advantage at all?
No tactical advantage?
At all?
Can you change the default text?
Why does it scare you, Kevin?
Is it scary?
Having default text?
Having no purpose?
Just being?
Is it just existing?
Is it giving you the heebie-jeebies?
Yes.
Very much.
I'm never...
Oh my god!
I'm killing you!
I'm gonna take a knife!
Tickle, tickle, tickle!
Look at her walking off all smug.
Don't smile at me.
How dare you push your movies on to Ryan?
That guy did nothing wrong.
Maybe...
Oh, whoops.
We will get a case then.
For our shinies.
We have quite a bit.
Oh my gosh, all the romance.
Default chat.
Laura Mipsum.
We should get some more.
more action, too.
Good job today, Ryan.
You killed it.
Wait, but my broken shiny.
Let's get one.
Shelves, maybe?
Where was it?
Decoration?
Equipment?
We got the TV, too.
Let's try getting that.
Oh, here, movie displays.
Let's get that, and let's get the television.
I don't know what the television does.
Okay.
What if, like, right here, right in the front, you can see
our lovely.
So, like, you?
Oh!
What else we got?
You, Beast Freak Show?
That one goes up top.
And, um...
Play movie tapes on it.
a TV up there so we can put one like right here oh what's it
showing what day is it Saturday yeah our little place is
filling up what if we put it like here is it too crowded
it's okay for now maybe on the the other side wait what if
like here like an end shelf thing you know you come in oh
look someone is gonna look at the window and be like what's
that i gotta watch that just a few more business days and
you can afford to expand the store just imagine it a proper
adult movie section we're gonna be rich ryan ryan ryan we're
gonna be rich we're gonna be rich
um i wonder what i can if can we really not fix these it's
so sad oh no okay goodbye nomad clown ah yes mad uh um don't
think we have any other shinies for now let's fix up our
shelving a little bit Yes, beautiful.
Yes, clean.
Yes.
The devs plan on adding a feature to repair tapes in an
update.
Oh, really?
Oh, that's good.
Let's check the market.
I don't think I checked it today.
Or maybe I did.
Oh, I did because we got the...
Romance, no?
All I need is my fast food!
It's a hot dog!
We'll get that.
What was I going to get?
I was going to get something.
The floating elephant in love.
Back alley dealer is only Tuesdays and Thursdays.
So sadly, not today.
More action?
We do need more action.
Let's see.
Is there any...
Wait, what was that?
Oh, the Forbidden Snake.
Let's see if we can get some stuff for like under 10 bucks.
right action 950 perfect it's exactly 950 exactly what i'm
talking about action 950 exact wait for what it's worth
shiny tapes do rent for more money so they do okay okay so
i'm not going crazy or anything well we can just put the
ones that we definitely don't like what if we ever get a
shiny version of, like, who ordered the hot T-Rex.
That would immediately go in the case.
We don't want anyone to ever destroy that.
One little VHS rental game to play at home.
Rent two movies and swap the tape reels between them.
Return.
You're evil.
Not at- If you did that at my store.
Binary ghosts.
You wouldn't.
You wouldn't at my store.
Right?
Right.
You wouldn't at my store.
Sell 20 slushy drinks.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
All rain all day.
So much rain.
So much.
I kind of want to put our haunting one.
The static haunting into the case too.
I like how Ghost of My Fantasy is just kind of Honestly I
feel I would put the T-Rex in the case On his own But I fear
I like seeing people rent him out You know what I mean I
kind of enjoy seeing the audience Getting the movie And
Enjoying it You know It's better to share T-Rex to the
world.
I agree.
Oh, yeah.
That's too shiny static.
It's rented every day.
As long as they don't break it.
Once it's not a new movie anymore, we'll put it in the case.
Once it's not a new movie.
Our adult section is nearly full.
They must know of its glory.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, Ryan?
What's wrong, Ryan?
What do you got a little exclamation point for?
Are you going to ask for a raise?
I'll give you one.
I've been throwing up all morning.
I won't be able to work today.
Why did you come in?
He won't even look at me.
No!
Uh-oh.
That means...
I have to do everything.
Ryan, you know we're trying to save up for an expansion
here, right?
I can't do it without you.
I can't do it without you, bud.
Can we get a temp?
A doctor's note, please?
Don't throw up on our tapes, Ryan.
Don't be that, boss.
I took days off because I was sick.
So I will let you take me off.
Where'd that mustache come from?
Wait, is this Ryan?
Who are you?
Wait a second.
Wait.
He got his, like, brother to come in and be like, Hey, boss.
No, stinking way.
That was...
The horse section is so small.
What are you talking about?
I'll order more variety.
There's like two, the whole shelves full.
That's his brother, Brian.
That was crazy.
That's why he wouldn't face us the whole time.
So...
That's not Ryan.
It was like a dramatic turn.
You need to go full black company.
No!
Throwing up has never made you grow a mustache before.
I wish.
Top 10 anime plot twists of all time.
It's so...
Evil Ryan says I'm gonna get out of work today.
With my moustache.
Now we have a third Ryan in Mint.
That Mint keeps getting confused with someone.
Why do we have another Ryan?
Why are we getting...
Where's all of my romance?
Oh, there they are.
Oh, the gas mask computer virus!
I'm glad that the devs seem to be...
Uh-oh.
Shoot.
um willing to upgrade the game or like update the game and
stuff all that's great okay not a lot of romance came in so
we might want to order some more next time he'll be bald
from the stress what if we made him work and then the next
day he came in ball he was like mad i can't do this anymore
can they quit they wouldn't quit would they Ryan, you need
this job.
Don't quit on me, buddy.
We're a family.
That's not my ride.
Vito, you pay a minimum wage.
You can't claim him like this.
No!
I'm parasocial to Ryan.
Tango with my wraith!
My milk never called.
Peasant space flight.
Alright, we need more action.
We'll do giant king attacks Manhattan.
That sounds great.
Kissing my gun machine in the sky.
It's the prequel to keeping my gun machine oiled up.
What?
Why don't more things do that?
Have like a movie that is for all people and then a sequel
that's a raunchy adult film.
It could be huge.
Trooper lost at sea.
The fairy's last dogfight.
What?
Why is the fairy dogfighting?
That's just...
That's just top of good.
Fire strike.
The burnt cookie.
Fear the keg.
I'm gonna get...
10 random movies.
and we'll save our $150.
Oh, shoot.
I just noticed that one.
You tell us.
I don't...
Why would I know?
Oh.
That's action.
Action.
Okay, we got a lot of good action, though.
Skylway to the fairy zone.
Officer bloodbath.
Wait, that's sick.
That's good.
Tango with my wraith.
The waitress strategy.
Well, what is it?
What's the strategy?
Guys, we're gonna make, like, no money today.
Because we don't have Ryan.
But that's okay.
We'll do our best.
our bus today is sunday there's nothing going on tomorrow
okay let's see robotic convention so more sci-fi movie
rentals that'll be great remembrance day more drama rentals
demolition derby more action then we get a new movie release
on tuesday oh task bonuses you're so right yes oh yes oh
nice we got $200 Sunday Sunday all right come on come on
don't say hmm oh what wait please okay oh they all come
scrambling as soon as it opens it's kind of Crazy.
Nomad gargoyle, got it.
Are you here for the static haunting?
Gosh, you're early.
Oh gosh, people are returning things.
Oh no, not more science fiction, please.
Actually, take it.
Take a science fiction.
Nice!
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, the lion is starting to back up already.
Ah!
Oh, I miss Ryan!
I miss Ryan!
I'm never gonna take it for granted again!
You can ask for...
You can ask for $19.
Old gem.
Uh...
old gem old gem oh my gosh the old g-force troll racer
Brian wants my love and the thing is is he only asked once
you know he shot his shot and he has just been a diligent
little worker ever since oh yeah the our snacks are going
baby it's kind of funny because like when i'm not working
the people are getting what's kind of go what's love
slightest spirit you know oh yeah it does get like an extra
dollar it's kind of big but it was on day one before he knew
it didn't he work because he knew how valuable he was i
don't need or he doesn't need me i need him i need i need
ryan please come back i don't want to do any manual labor
anymore Bro, owning a business, I got comfortable.
Owning a business is hard.
We're not going to be able to get any flyers.
I know how this works.
You randomly assign late fees to customers just to make an
extra buck.
Well, I'm not falling for it.
Well, pay up, buddy.
I hate this place.
Ah!
New release.
There you go.
This jerk.
You're gonna miss out on kissing my organ in the sky.
You're missing out.
It's your fault.
So rude.
Sorry you had to witness that, Amelia.
That was disgusting behavior.
Now what?
Two?
I need to pay a late fee.
Wait, I'm a good customer.
You're the store owner, right?
Just cancel the fee.
You're running up.
See?
Yeah.
You saw that I was gonna kill that other guy.
so I can't believe she betrayed me like that she betrayed me
like that after she's how could she do that to me what if we
okay crazy thought making this our logo for the store and
another Another old film?
Okay, um, something in action.
Because our store is called Ghostbuster and that little
sticker says, no ghost!
You know?
Try it.
Okay.
Oh, yes.
You don't think anybody will like come after me and be like,
hey, we're suing you into oblivion.
You'll never work in this town or ever again.
You have to move and change your name and get a mustache.
That won't happen to us?
No, it's safe.
Okay, cool.
Who would do that?
Four guys from New York are filing suit?
Oh my gosh.
Dang, Xavier!
You're free to go.
Do you think they miss Ryan, too?
Do you think they say, wow, this current cashier is really
competent and fast.
But I just missed the...
The, you know, white bread energy.
The white toast energy of the guy that used to be behind the
counter.
He literally gave us nothing.
He was just a dude.
And you're free to go?
The moderate average speed.
It didn't feel intimidating, you know?
They didn't feel like...
Like they were getting stressed by how fast he was going.
Is this what happened to Ryan?
Did he grow his mustache out to run from copyright?
No.
That would never happen to us because Ryan is our fall guy,
so he's kidding.
It was in his contract.
He just didn't, you know, nobody reads them, so.
All right.
We got a lot more movies coming in.
Oops, dang it.
I did not mean to do that.
I like to grab all the same genre at once, you know?
So much easier.
late late
just making sure it still said drama on it you know drama
okay yes sorry you have too many movies to choose from can
you help me pick a good one a good movie bad bad bad good
Martian storm fury it's great I've literally sold it to my
grandma yesterday.
Dream Hunter Rem is an anime that started out as an HOVA.
People just kind of like the action and character enough to
sideline the lude.
That's so good.
Wait, we did make a decent amount of money, all things
considered.
I suffer from temporal blur disorder.
My sense of time is permanently blurred.
It's not my fault.
You have a watch.
Yeah, she'll pay it.
She said, you make a fine argument.
The slow turn.
Nobody's getting adult movies anymore.
Have all our freaks run out of content?
Nobody wants adult movies anymore?
Was it just a fad?
Why the slow turn?
I don't know, they're freaky.
Hey.
Could they at least say please?
You know?
Please.
Instead of hey.
Stop slow turning at me.
It's freaking me out.
Everybody seems possessed.
Whoa.
Oh, Dennis!
quiet time with the dinosaur, eh?
Someone's a little softy, you know?
You're free to go.
Oh, wow.
$700, you guys.
Yeah.
Hag power up.
Yacht power up.
Ryan, who...
Honestly, I thought you made so much money by getting people
in the door but like we actually kind of i don't want to say
we didn't need him but we were not lost without him it was
ryan's presence that made them want to watch the adults film
you may not like this truth but you must accept it wait
which ones were these I think these were the wait I think
those were also plenty of people were getting adult films
when I was behind the register don't lie to me I think they
were the super chips right people we like in the chips let's
get some more Freddy's let's get some more caramel alright
I'm not jealous I'm speaking the truth you're slandering my
good name
fairy between our heart how did that happen there we go
we'll get we'll put that up top yeah yeah all right finish
off Oh, it's quiet in here without him though, isn't it?
That guy is a yapper.
He goes, Ryan, Ryan, Ryan all day like a dang Pokemon.
I miss his little voice.
For all we know, Ryan's like in the hospital.
He's fighting for his life.
What do we do with the chairs?
One thing that I learned...
is about in the UK they have, you know how like there's the
naughty corner like the timeout corner you know when you're
bad and they're like go to their timeout corner and reflect
on what you've done in the UK they have the naughty step I
want to put it like hold on
yes so in the way
up it's so in the way
perfect all right we can shut down
369 oh we got the popcorn machine it can be repaired what
the hell is oh it's the robotics convention wait is this the
little guy that I can buy for $999?
Ryan, you're home!
And you shaved!
I don't think...
Guys, I really think we got bamboozled yesterday.
I don't think that was Ryan.
How's the best boss in the world doing today?
Oh, what are you doing?
Huh?
Where are you going?
Wait, you didn't clock in.
Wait, can he not get to the...
Can you... Wait, you didn't clock in.
I guess you did.
Okay, so sci-fi is on the rise.
We'll fill the shelf up.
Oh.
We'll get used to it being there.
What do we got today on the market?
Movie bundles, the coffin's famous pie.
Can't wait for Ghostbuster Gaiden Ryan's sick day.
The machine, forever yours!
It's really bad.
The mind reader, my soulmate.
Climbing parent mountain.
Operation Toaster Barn Assault, but it has zero stars.
The gambler moving on!
No!
Don't move on!
Double down!
That's been a fair amount of time.
I'm on the naughty step in my early days.
No, you didn't.
Go to the naughty step.
He didn't lock in.
He gave up.
The chair was just too clever for him.
Ryan works for free now.
The elf's wrong number.
That is a fairy.
This is messed up.
This is actually messed up.
We know that's a fairy.
Right, everybody?
We know.
Oh, I clip through it.
Oh Romance Alright let's get through All of these Alright we
have way too many sci-fives That's good though As soon as
people start grabbing them Oops We can Start replacing
immediately
One second please One second please Oh I have a second I
have a second one one second please one second oh I did it
again oops I there we go there we go this is Melissa calling
on behalf of sea life awareness we're reaching out to you
the urgent situation involving endangered sea turtles may I
have a moment of your time sorry wrong number looked more
like a gnome to me I think you need to get your eyes checked
Fokuro Fokuro What?
Where do you see no?
Tell me.
Tell me where...
Oops.
Do you see no?
That's craziness.
Where'd all our color violet go?
Bottom right.
Is it because I...
Shiggin.
Ask you for the night.
Oh, thank you, Pepe.
Sorry, wrong number.
I should have just hung up on that guy.
10831364.
Oops.
Table 4-2 with RTRX.
We'll grab that in a second.
Oh, these are just horror.
Awesome.
Save.
All right.
You go there.
Thank you very much, everybody, for all the wonderful
movies.
Honestly, I don't think our business would be as booming
without all your great recommendations.
This is us fellow entrepreneurs.
We gotta stick together, you know?
We gotta tell each other what the hot new stuff is so that
we can have the best possible you know experience like give
our customers the best possible experience no Ryan doesn't
have his mustache I actually think that that was not Ryan
unless he was like hey boss I feel sick because I grew this
sick mustache you know this sick stash and that's one thing
what if he was just joking with wait mixed sometimes they
don't like show up with in the order that i have picked them
up in you know
actually what if we just like throw these on the bottom here
what if we just you know who's gonna notice who's gonna tell
there we go Ryan is a shapeshifter.
I've got my eye on you, buddy.
Let's fix the popcorn?
Repair!
Ooh.
Oh, it smells yummy.
Alright, and let's open up.
Ryan, all you today.
What a jerk.
You can smell it you can smell it smell so good.
You're back.
What do you oh color violet.
Okay You didn't like it meh meh he says Oh my god, they
really just start flocking as soon as you open up
Not interested what about you what about you ooh ooh Waldo
is back baby I don't what I like about this game is I don't
think people like it.
What's the word?
I don't think they get Uh tired of waiting so I don't feel
so stressed, you know where I'm like oh my gosh if I don't
handle these people in a timely manner At least it hasn't
happened yet.
So Static haunting oh you're lucky that you came early
Thanks for the popcorns!
Wait, hold on.
I'm opening up a bustin ghost across the street.
My rentals will be a dollar cheaper and we will forgive late
fees for our loyal customers.
You're just gonna open one up for fun, huh?
You just think that you could open up your own video rental
store?
You know what?
I was in the womb.
womb thinking about owning a video rental store this is my
life my blood my afterlife my genes is owning and running a
video rental store and you think you could just open one up
without any passion you think you could just open up what
open one up without any passion without ever without without
without Even considering the movie markets.
You think I go out in the back alley and you think that I
talked to that tape dealer?
Literally, I have a wanted sign for him.
You think I talk to him because I have a choice?
No, I love movies and I love owning a video rental movie
store because I have the passion for it.
And I love giving flyers to people.
I stand out there in the rain.
I stand out there in the goddamn rain.
I'm soaked to the bone.
My brochures, my flyers, they're soaked as well.
And I'm still passing them out This is my life!
This is my everything!
I sunk every dollar into this.
You know the profits that you see in the corners?
That is my actual...
That's my bank account.
You see all the money that goes back into my store.
Everything is for the store.
And you think that you could just open one up across the
street.
Really, really.
Like, you're just going to be like, I'm bored.
I'm going to open up a video rental store today.
that don't pay their late fees and you have customers that
will push the bags of movies that they rented onto you and
even slushies that spills everywhere and you have customers
that ask for adult movies without any shave I like that part
though but also you have movie you have customers that break
movies it's not for the weak of the heart what if who
ordered a hot T-Rex got broken the next day.
Would you be able to handle it?
I don't think so.
So next time you think about opening and running a video
rental store, think about that.
Think about that right now.
Stick it to the man.
Yeah.
You got the part.
You think I'm acting?
You think I'm doing this for fun?
It's my passion.
Passion.
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna kill you for not liking my video rental store.
I might have gone a little overboard, and I apologize.
It really comes from a place of passion.
Do you have any copies of Minto?
Is the cutest in the world?
Stop it!
We're all out.
Love the enthusiasm.
Thank you!
Today is Monday.
Okay, cool.
Let's keep these shelves stocked, baby.
Stocked, stocked, stocked.
Okay, I thought it would be flying off the shelves, but...
Quiet time with a fight.
Dinosaurs broken!
This is what I made.
You can't handle it.
Can't handle the truth.
Watch.
Oh no, the color violet is not new anymore.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's because we have a new movie coming out, it's okay.
I can't believe it!
Oh.
No!
I heard that you settled down, that you found a girl and
you're married now.
I heard that your dreams came true, but she gave you things
I couldn't give to you.
Oh, Dino, why are you so shy?
like you to hold back.
I've tried to put it up the normal.
The high from the line.
There's no time for tears though.
We have somebody wanting a rental.
The nomad gargoyle.
Never mind I'll find a dino like you.
I will There's nothing but the best for you to...
Check the skew and order it again?
Yeah, but it's not the same, you guys.
I can't just get a...
I mean, I can get a replacement, but...
Your first is always, you know...
It's always special.
are you two don't forgive me i'll remember your name quiet
time with the dinosaur quiet time with the dinosaur your
toes taste like mint not an april fools joke no they don't
they don't sorry 173.
109.82773.
It says I have one.
It's expensive!
No.
I can't do it.
Oops.
I can't bring myself to do it.
Erm.
Alright, anyways.
Back to work.
Back to work, everybody.
Wow, the romance is flying off the shelves.
What do you want?
A horror movie that is old.
Lucky for you.
I have hag on death.
Why is hag on death row old?
That's so funny.
Can we put it?
No, you can't put broken ones in the display, sadly.
I tried before.
Murder.
Oh, our dramas are, like, pretty full, actually.
You, you, you, you, you.
We'll keep this one.
And all of these go into the pile.
Nice.
Great business strategy, everybody.
The blood-sucking paladin.
I do have that for you, ma'am.
the shiny one on display.
But I want to put like shiny ones of my favorite movies.
You know what I mean?
Like, uh...
Like...
Um...
How do I say?
Like ones that I'm worried about getting destroyed.
But they're shiny.
There.
Up there.
An owner's collection.
Yeah, it's my collection.
A new release!
Sorry, I can't help you, man.
I can't help you.
Sorry.
Oh, hot dog, fast food hacker.
My own personal collection.
Everybody take a look at all these great movies.
A drama that's good.
I got you?
The Wraith family tree?
one i i put my afterlife on i that's how important this one
is to me this one is amazing i'm sorry the customer broke
your movement though it's okay i'll get over it you know
look we're almost 800 we once we get to a thousand we can
expand tomorrow what if oh my gosh what if if tomorrow we
could expand all right thank you bye oh i forgot to do the
rentals or the no i think i did the the ones that were
coming back tape guy tomorrow oh you're right new movie is
bad dreams on mel road which that definitely says mel street
but that's fine that's okay
um we'll put this over here can i put this over here okay
let's do this
oh nope wait i actually wonder if this will make it more
difficult to put the movie this thing here
oh no we got it nice after your impassioned speech i have
decided to go another direction I will make a mail order
movie rental That will never work Everybody loves analog
You'll be going under in like Ten minutes It's 1990 Baby
What you think that this will be huge in like 20 years No
way Jose some ghostly SKUs thank you Give me more skews.
695, 2, 3, 2, 3, 1.
In bed with the ghost!
Oh, it's expensive, though.
Okay, we'll have to pass.
But I like it.
I like how all the adult movies start with 6, 9.
I have noticed that.
A song for my ghost!
That's also your Lion April.
The cougar wants my ghost.
Why are these so expensive?
It could be huge in 20 years.
you never know no no i'm a prophet i'm a prophet you don't
understand in 20 years it will all everything will still be
the same literally nothing will happen and no crazy
life-changing world events will happen as well everyone will
still be coming to ghostbusters business will still be
booming
Ghost.
Are she beautiful?
We are entering the age of stability.
She played as the doctor waited.
Wait!
No way!
You're lying, April!
Hey, that was actually your lie in April!
No!
Who keeps breaking my movies?
Sad, sad, sad.
Oh wait, we have the new movie we have to order as well.
Oh, wait, we have the new movie we have to order as well.
I don't remember the words.
Excuse me, ma'am, but do you have a permit for that video
store and do you have the proper licenses to sell all those
videos?
I'm going to need to see those or I'll have to shut this
place down.
business regulation um first of all I'm not selling any
movies this is only rental so I don't need any per permits
for selling okay but for rental I've got it right here let's
get the new movie
Boy.
Undenought.
What do you do with the old standees when you don't want
them anymore?
You give them to people that beg for it.
I'll never forget.
There was one time.
I was trying to...
For some reason, my brain wants to say Kingdom Hearts.
It was a standee for a game.
I want to say it was Kingdom Hearts, but I really don't
think it was.
I went to that game store.
every day.
I was like, you're going to put me on the name for the
person that takes home the Kingdom Hearts Dandy, right?
I wonder if there's a movie adaptation for a certain
Minotaur film.
There could be!
But now that I think about it, you know how like...
But they put me down for the name as the person that was
like...
They were like, yeah, we have you and your number for the...
Um...
For the...
Whoops.
Stand-E.
They never called me.
They never did.
But now that I think about it, if it was Kingdom Hearts, I
imagine they probably...
Some companies don't like to...
You know, they actually only want to destroy their stuff.
I'm pretty sure Nintendo is that way.
Like, you'll never...
You'll, like, very rarely find somebody with, like, a
Stand-E and Nintendo Stand-E or something.
from my understanding but some of them are I wonder if they
were like very adamant like this this needs to be destroyed
but when I was a kid I didn't know that I had no idea also
why are we getting so many horror movies that one guy that
keeps calling that's like your horror selection sucks is
going to be very excited yeah Disney might well be that's
what I was thinking just like now it came to me i have a
mario cart ds sandy oh nice i know somebody with a splatoon
sandy but i have heard that nintendo maybe it's like with
mario wait you just said mario cart i don't know maybe it's
you get lucky right it's like a very hush hush some
companies require proof that we destroyed promotional
materials oh no way where can i find the hot dog section oh
my gosh a magical I'm so glad you asked.
We have here the Fast Food Hacker.
We have a hot dog in every genre.
We have the Light Keepers hot dog.
We have, we have, we have rooster and sausage.
We have, we quite literally, I think, actually have a movie
for every genre with a hot dog in it.
Didn't your old roomie have a standy of Oscar Isaac?
Oh yeah, she did.
Rafi Rafael, thank you so much for the tangented!
Yeah, yeah.
I also had a standee of Tom Clancy's Splinter Cell, which is
so funny.
I had never played Splinter Cell.
I don't even remember how I acquired it.
I think my sister got it and was like, Minto, you like video
game.
So she gave it to me.
Can I get a chocolate hot dog?
Sam Fisher.
Yes.
I had one.
And it's so funny because now, I would have never thunk
that...
Table for two with our T-Rex?
I never would have thunk that.
I mean, I'm not...
Not that I've played it, but like...
I'm so Metal Gear-brained.
And it's like, you know, kind of a sister series.
It's so funny.
Also, today, guys, remind me, please, that we need to
visit...
the guy in the alleyway.
We're going to clean this up.
Maybe it looks ugly, and that's why people don't like it.
Alright.
Oh.
Hi.
I'm on the counter.
Oh.
All of our rentals.
I forgot we didn't do this.
Movie rental corporate espionage tactic.
Rent out all the competing stores as new releases.
Soon people will think that store in a rest.
Good stuff.
You just slap your own label on it instead.
Genius market.
I think that was our only horror movie with a hot dog!
Oh, Satan and his hot dog!
We are losing our best titles, you guys.
This is actually tragic.
Hey, boss, don't forget to visit the guy in the alley.
Thank you!
This is so bad.
I cannot believe.
Mint a Batara movie.
Mint's favorite book adaptation.
I'm scared.
You have me scared.
Hag ghost story.
If we weren't so full on horror, I'd get it.
This one I'm scared.
It's so expensive.
Thank you for the codes!
Thank you for the Super Chachi!
Remember when I was a kid that a friend's older brother had
a cardboard standy of some lame video game called Metal
Gear?
I was an ignorant child!
I feel like...
I feel like if that Splinter Cell standy had been a Metal
Gear standy, and I was like, I don't know what the heck this
is.
and i yeah i did almost hit five before looking at the price
hot dog is broken romance is broken too but if i if it had
been metal gear and like i was like i don't know what the
heck this is and then eventually you know obviously i got
rid of the standy eventually like i just would have i just i
don't know say he i worked at game stop when kingdom hearts
dream draw distance came out and I bought the stand oh I
brought the standee for you home sadly I think it's more
likely that no one at your location thought to give the
little ghosty a call but it was time to throw it out I'm
sorry it's okay I was so like I was so diligent about going
maybe I just annoyed them to pieces but I was like I need
this standee I need it I need it I need it and they they
took a sticky note they wrote my name and my phone number
adult minotaur movie sounds saying I don't I I'd watch it
I'd watch it for sure
is that stiff PC no way oh my god it came back I had an MGS
2 standing from my local blockbuster as a kid it was the
last MGS I played Mickey inspired me to pick up MGS Delta
the other day though yay I hope you like it I don't know
though I feel like you need a bit of a It's like quite the
gap.
Stiff PC came home.
All right.
Maybe...
I wonder if the chair is in the way.
And that's why nobody is getting the...
I just realized.
It could be very much that.
We'll try it.
We'll experiment.
This is so...
I think this is our only hot dog themed horror movie.
Now I don't have a hot dog for every genre.
This is so sad.
Tiny Baby King, welcome back.
The Black Market guy?
He's only at night, though, right?
It's only after closing, yeah.
Never mind how fine someone like you.
I'm, I'm, I'm washed.
I, my, I feel like we should rebrand as like a hot dog
Emporio or something, you know.
Wow.
Yeah, wow.
Oh, you're already on your way here.
What about you?
You look like you could use them good.
Oh yeah, you're already coming.
Okay.
My ghost is washed.
Like, I'm a fraud now.
I can't even say.
I can't even...
I just...
It's so sad.
Oh.
Oops.
I think my movies here are starting to...
Don't mind the movies here.
Yes?
Yacht movie?
Yacht.
I'm gonna go crazy.
You need to pay the fee.
I think they're nicer to Ryan than they are to me.
I have a seeking suspicion that they have not thrown slushy
at Ryan yet.
Hmm.
I know Ryan's just doing his job.
I'm doing my job.
Can't a ghost just try to make it unliving?
Come on, then.
I just, this is my store.
Like, please.
He's got charm.
Everybody loves Ryan.
Hello.
Where are the customers?
Everybody's at Magic Scoop.
Oh, you're already coming over.
Where did you guys come from?
I just lost.
Oh.
I'm losing customers.
Potential customers.
Superliminal, thank you!
One hot dog from the Hot Dog Emporium, please.
We can call it Movies and Dogs.
How about that?
Well, we're gonna do a rebrand.
Oh.
Thank you.
Movies and Dogs.
Oh.
Where?
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
You coming in?
Yeah.
Movies and dogs.
And red.
Red.
Actually, the light will be...
Uh...
How do I make it...
You know what?
That's fine.
moving dinos and dogs wait that's even better dogs and dinos
dogs and dinos dogs and dinos oh yeah espionage tactic 3
rent competing stores movies and dub commercials for your
store with coming soon oh yes yes Okay.
There you are, sir.
You're welcome.
I want to save your lie in April.
Hoi!
Maybe in the update, the movies will still be broken, you
know?
Maybe in the update.
Oh, I remember you!
You're enamored?
My store is just that.
Awesome, right?
Oh, look at this.
It looks too good.
It looks so good.
Why is everybody going, hmm?
Are you not pleased?
Dino.
Why?
No, everybody.
Static haunting.
Oh, you reserved it.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, the new movie is coming out.
It's getting sold out, too.
Please?
please.
Woopies give me bad headaches.
Man, man, man.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
Yes.
Hello, Mr. Wonka.
Hmm.
Not interested.
This guy is.
All right, let's do some movies.
Let's get some back on the shelves.
Let her to my breakfast.
Oh, come on.
How you doing, Ryan?
The lion's chugging along.
Luckily, these people are patient.
They love you.
The camera loves you, buddy.
Can't believe we lost our hot dog.
Oops.
I hate this.
I picked it up as... I picked up all the romance together
all the sci-fi together and yet
it's all over when they break your hot dog true
to prevent nuclear fission i recommend headpats sound theory
i think
so many science fiction this must be from the robot
convention we have so many excuse me sorry sorry I don't
mean to get in your way I'm just restocking the shelves so
that you have more selection for a greater experience for
yourself the client Willie Walker look there's more there's
more he looked he looked at me he was really excited what
are you doing um hello Hey, it's the 90s, baby.
Things break, but we move on, right?
No need to charge me.
Charge.
I'll be more careful.
It was a 20th...
Wait.
What did you break?
A bad movie.
Which one did he break?
He broke my heart.
That's what he did.
No matter what movie he broke, my heart is crushed.
Slushy.
Oops.
Satan and his hot dog.
Don't say that!
If it really was!
Oh gosh.
I can't take it!
I gotta get out of this business.
You can rent movies on your TV on demand!
You don't need VHS cassettes anymore.
Don't you... How dare you?
Don't you love the smell?
of a freshly wound VHS tape.
Espionage tactic died.
Are you good?
Maybe you should stop thinking of espionage tactics and you
should be...
We're busy running your business.
Oh, another one?
No.
I'll go to another video store next time.
Yeah, don't come back.
What did you say?
I missed it.
Actually, hold on.
Pay people to loiter in a competing store and make the
experience uncomfortable for legitimate customers.
No!
Hold on, I'm going to save real quick.
Oh, the door is open.
We'll wait for the people to go.
Someone might be an undercover cop, you know.
We'll wait for them to leave.
Look, our stock changes every day because we have room for
it.
Today, I discovered Kojima produces helped with the story of
one of my fave games growing up, Castlevania Lords of
Shadow.
I hope you'll check it out.
Oh!
I know that he's done, like, other Konami like, story and
stuff.
Like, how...
Pretty sure he helped with, like, Tokimeki and everything,
even.
Um...
I do like Castlevania, though.
Once rented tape broke in...
Once rent... Wait, once a rented tape broke on our VCR, my
father glued it back together with Scotch tape.
I don't think that's how you glue it.
I think that's how you I have no idea if that fixed it.
We never rented it again.
No!
You are those people!
What do we got?
Best tapes in town.
Exclusive picks.
The dentist in good hands.
A personal favorite of mine.
Good pick.
They created the first dynamite.
Sure, it's $4.
Smoke in the velvet room.
Woo!
The Martian temple.
Astronaut's blood.
Where's the saucy?
You're only going to give us one movie this time?
Dealer, if you don't bring better movies, there isn't going
to be a deal.
Err.
Slam it in his face.
Hire an overly chatty nerd to hang out at one of the stores
in particular and make it awkward?
No!
Day 85 of Drawing, Buddy Mint comes closer and closer!
Thank you!
Guys, we're so close to expanding.
Alright.
Good night, Ryan.
300.
Wait, we didn't get so many movies rented.
another day of rain all it's been doing is raining raining
raining hi ryan you look good today no mustache yeah how'd
you grow it that fast yeah very curious about that oh
reserved
arch idea a minto karaoke stream on VHS.
That would be something.
Oh, the shiny one's reserved.
Nice.
I can't tell when things become reserved or not.
Hmm.
Like, why that one is reserved?
Why not another one?
Oops.
Why Why that version?
Legitimate and legal business tactic.
Take our life insurance policies on your employers.
See black company operations or further instructions.
This game gives me chill as art vibes.
Am I weird?
No.
I think...
I think it's just like a simulator game sort of, you know.
Let's see.
Let's put the shiny one up here.
They have a lot of those games where it's just like, do the
thing, and you do the thing.
I wouldn't even say this game is janky, to be honest.
I think it does quite a good job.
Honestly.
Oh, nice.
Hag power up.
Oh, man.
It's getting popular now.
Probably in high school, Dad would get bootleg DVDs, before
they release in the US, and bad misprints.
I watch Zombieland in Russian dub.
Scrimander three day?
And my favorite, the hills have noses.
No way, that doesn't sound real.
Rented stiff PC three times.
No, we're out of space, we're out of space.
Hold on, I'll go get the, oh.
I went to branch out, but I'm afraid nothing can live up to
that masterpiece.
really that hot you have no idea hey I've got a few movies
at home I don't watch anymore do you take donations I'll
drop them in the drop box in the back no way oh what do you
got sunset beggar the barrel under the bed dr. Lane's chosen
visitor and the clown night feeder whoa let's drop these on
the floor I think sunset.
There we go.
You can also go on the shelf.
Let's drop them on the floor.
Wow, some people just give you movies for free!
Actually, so, when I go to Japan, sometimes I'll, like, you
know, I'll go to Mandarake.
Actually, here's a story for anybody who tries to do the
same thing as me.
I go to, I bring, like, anime figures and stuff to
Mandarake.
that they will accept like you just put your address and
they'll accept like uh your driver's license or something
now um but this time uh i had gone to an idol event where
she sold um a gravier book and the books were way thicker
than i thought they were going to be and i had five of them
they were huge and they were very heavy so i was like okay i
will i will sell off a couple of these so that i can get
home yeah i had to get five so i could get a picture with
her and also so that i could um i just had to get five okay
guys anyway um
one to Steiner.
I gave one to Steiner and then I was like okay I will take
the rest to book off.
And then I also had some clothes and some book offs will
take clothes.
So I was like I will give my books and I will give my
clothes to book off.
And so I took it there.
Wait a second.
Oops.
I just noticed this one.
Um I took it and I was like okay here's my stuff.
Here's my books and they were like okay for books we can
only take um up to two per person or something so i you know
i had more than that so i was like okay that's fine um but
then um and i had to take my clothes to another floor and i
went back down to where uh because they they give you like a
little number and they're like we'll call your number when
you uh when we're ready to like give you the price of your
books And I was like, okay, cool.
And so I wandered around and then they called me and I went
over and they were like, okay, we need all this information
from you, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And so I gave it all to them.
And then they were like, okay, um, do you live in Japan?
I was like, uh-uh.
And they were like, oh, that's like a problem.
Because like, you cannot, we cannot buy these things unless
you have a Japanese address.
But I was like, oh.
Dang.
I don't know why.
Especially because Mandarake is able to buy back stuff.
So, I was like, shoot.
The books, the clothes I could manage.
But the books, I was like, these are so heavy.
I won't be able to bring these back.
But luckily, they were like, do you want to donate them to
book off?
We will recycle them.
And, like, you know, and I was like...
fine
so if you go to japan expecting to like sell your clothes or
your books or whatever um at book off uh you cannot unless
you have a japanese address so word of warning for you all
and then for then the guy was so nice though because he knew
that i was donating clothes as well and as as i was leaving
he he like ran outside and he stopped me And he was like, by
the way, I know you were trying to donate clothes as well.
Do you want those back?
Like, you, or do you want me to tell the guy that you just
want to donate those as well?
And I just ended up, they were going to get donated either
here.
You know, I was going to take them to like a thrift store.
Or, so I was like, oh, I could make like a couple bucks off
of it.
You know, I was like, that's, you know, whatever.
But, so they weren't going to get donated regardless.
I just was like, I'll try to I'll try to get a little bit of
cash So it was no big deal, but dang Yeah, I was a nice guy
Did you see the trailer for live action He-Man?
No?
Oh, it looked too...
Wait, I'm hopeful for the live action Hey, I, I, I, I, I It
looked too expensively to be April Fool's I don't think it's
April Fool's right now So I don't think America's doing
April Fool's right now
Yeah, I was nice to him do right by you.
He was really like, he was like, oh, I was like, it's okay.
But dang, what a stinky policy that now I know about.
Only go to Mandarake if you were trying to sell things.
I probably could have taken the books to Mandarake, but I
was on a bit of a time crunch, so yeah.
Now we know.
Komaru was very troubled all right oh yes we did all our
returns our reserves are completely full Ryan keep up the
good work wait what is that 10% of resign what does that
mean work faster let's go
oh yeah oh someone is someone had a great time with this
movie oh he's a howdy duty that's what he said my story is
so green it's kind of awesome it was like a 10% oh of him
quitting oh wait then we could just tell him to work faster
10% is pretty uh 10% I feel is pretty oh my gosh the time
actually flies with this game.
I cannot believe it's almost been four hours.
No stinking way.
There's no way.
10% are high gotcha odds.
No, no, no.
Well, kind of.
If you put it in gotcha perspective, maybe.
Hello.
Oh my god, why did you look like that?
Oh my god.
God!
Here you go!
Good Lord!
Hi!
You haven't been coughing as much today too.
It's funny because I was, as I coughed, but I coughed a lot
this morning.
But now?
Oh, can I do my inhaler real quick?
You guys mind?
One second.
Hold on, I'm gonna pause.
Don't mute, I haven't been muting.
Oh, I do need to take on my steroid.
I don't think I should take it with coffee.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta go get another drink.
It says at bedtime.
I didn't have dinner yet.
What time is it?
Gosh, it's late.
Wait, did I say?
Can I take my second pill?
Hold on, I have to count these.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Coffee at 11 p.m.
I didn't know what time it was.
One, two.
Okay, yeah, I took my pills today.
There's too many pills, I'm getting so.
All right.
Okay.
Wow.
Okay, I'm gonna go get another drink.
I didn't realize how late it had gotten.
Truly.
What are you looking at?
You're being a little weirdo.
Blood-sucking paladin, I got it.
Oh, what do you want?
Hag power up?
She relates?
This game makes the time fly by.
It honestly does.
It's so fun.
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna go get a drink.
and put my coffee in the fridge.
Okay, BRB.
I was just sitting here thinking, like, man, I'm starting to
get hungry.
I should, like, I should think about dinner.
Maybe I'll order a pizza.
A pizza.
I might get a pizza, but then now I'm looking at the time.
I mean, luckily, pizza stores are usually open late, right?
It's like 11 p.m.
for me.
Owl's Pizza Palace.
certain games have like completely changed my brain
chemistry you know like there's just some games that like i
can't stop quoting i can't i can't stop thinking about
druids is one of them owls pitzer palace the best pitzer in
all of linda
spin hush tactic no more no more please thank you for the
sewer doesn't buy there he goes but your wallet please
please thank you we snipe them as they walk in get a hot dog
i don't know i feel like pizza is like i i can have like two
slices and be good or one slice you know
hold on i can still get her I can't get her.
She's too fast.
Wait, I can kiss it.
I can get her.
I can...
Thank you for all the zoom and chitz.
Let us pick the toppings for you.
No.
I know what I want.
You will have no say in my dinner.
We need more.
romance for real oh and then you guys mentioned not coughing
i'm so scared every time i get something now that i like
like a movie i'm scared that it's gonna be broken my heart
is is fragile now
hello oh thank goodness the beast is here
pineapple and ham The static haunting.
Yeah, we do actually have that.
Oops.
Oh.
I had little seizures with pretzel crust.
It was good.
Wait, that does sound good.
I was going to put pineapple.
What I want is wrong!
Why?
You guys, we have enough for the upgrade.
We have enough?
We have one.
$1,000!
Yeah!
Ryan, we're going we're going corporate!
We're going it's huge!
Wait, we can get more people.
Come here.
Oh, scientist, man.
Oh, look.
Yes.
You also have a movie.
You don't.
You want to fly?
What?
How does a movie give you a bad headache?
Maybe I'm just being a hater.
Actually, she's just being a hater.
Yeah, we're going big, baby.
The Martian Temple?
Are you here for the Martian Temple?
Imagine she called and made the reservation like Right in
here.
Oh, ma'am, the dentist is in good hands.
and in your hands indeed.
No way, you literally called from outside the store for the
Martian temple.
You did exactly what I just said you were going to do.
Flashing lights.
Okay, that's fair.
But not all movies have flashing lights.
I can reach her.
Yes.
We got a customer.
Some can be overly fluid or detailed.
Okay, stop.
You guys, I understand that people can get headaches from
movies.
But, this is my job and my passion.
Thank you.
Okay, I don't think any more people are coming in.
while you finish up with those people I'll handle this
don't strain yourself no I'm about to finish up all good we
will buy the expansion and then we'll finish up no worries I
don't feel bad if you guys are concerned I do just have a
bit of a curve oops that's just me recovering my coughs do
not hurt by the way in case you're also concerned about that
we can put some more of these up here yes yes very good oh
we're cleaning up the place real nice nice and then I think
there yeah two more one more oh dang table for two with rt
rex is popular sasuga dogs and dynos
um very nice can i expand i
heard something happened whoa oh Whoa!
Whoa!
Impulse buy, it wasn't!
Pizza finds, thank you Phil!
No, no more Phil, thank you.
Tomorrow we will also meet with the guy.
Oh my gosh.
We have so much more room for activities!
Okay, now we can ask.
actually like we can go insane without all this space this
is crazy
yeah i wish it didn't take me out of the editor every time i
play something well
um more snacks actually our snacks have not been selling so
well have they let's put it like here wow this is crazy
We have so much space.
Oh, it feels good.
I can, like, I can do this.
Yeah, you know, you know.
Creepy little horror corner.
This can go here.
Are happy.
Balloons can go right next to the snacks.
This is looking good!
Watch this, watch this.
The naughty.
No, you come over here?
You can sit down and watch a little something something and
it's muted but don't worry about it.
Can I edit what this is?
Uh, oh, I can adjust the volume!
Huh?
They're Minecraft.
Play your video.
Retro, rewind, content, movies.
Wait, actually?
Replace the file!
We could put whatever we want!
Wait, that's fun!
Oh no.
use custom files.
Wait, that's so good.
Yeah, Den said two MVPs.
I was thinking something similar.
Adult movie.
How is an adult movie less than a new release?
All right, let's fix this up too.
I do, I do, I wish I could like sell stands so we could like
of you know standardize everything but it's okay for how it
is right now wow there's so much room there's so much room
oh you can sell them you can huge news for me
good job ryan we made a great uh one small step for man
large step for dinos and dogs video rental store dogs and
dinos shoot they're they're interchangeable it's fine let's
close the day wait oh yeah let's close the day
we unlocked christmas movies on the second day of christmas
it's oh it's fall wait what about halloween We're not even
at Halloween.
Oh, I died in a tree.
And what else did we unlock?
The Nutcracker and Gifts.
Armor.
Okay, I'm assuming we'll get fantasy sometime then.
We're missing fantasy?
Comedy?
Diehard unlocked?
Okay.
What else?
Fantasy, comedy, kids, westerns, kung fu?
Good amount, then.
If they have those other ones, right?
Clearance Bin is level 10.
What level are we?
I don't even know anymore.
Wait.
Uh, we're level 9!
So clearance bin is next, baby.
That's what we will be working towards because we gotta get
rid of all of these.
So, um, we'll...
We'll work today, right?
Or rather, next time, we will work the day.
And then we will...
Also, like, a back-to-back snack machine?
Everyone's kryptonite!
Um...
Or snack stand?
We will work, and then we will, um, buy more shelves and
stuff.
Yeah.
I wish I could, like, put it on top.
It'd be so cute.
No!
Thanks for making the best dog and dino video store.
Have a good night and enjoy your pizza.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Roll up snacks for the checkout line.
It's, like, a real...
It becomes a real video store.
No.
This has always been a real rental video store.
It has.
Who ordered the hot T-Rex?
Damn.
Hot dog my fantasy.
We will have to get our hot dog horror film back.
But...
We made great progress, everybody.
We made astounding progress.
Look, I'm as happy as this guy.
Yippee!
And now...
Oh, we can make it... Wow!
We can make it like crazy.
Oh, I see the difference now.
So...
I think...
No, I don't see the difference.
Never mind.
I'm a liar.
Make your store bigger!
Bigger, bigger, bigger!
Yeah.
Then we'd have this area expanded.
this looks like a separate room some of these look like like
this looks like a separate room and this too because it has
like the two doorways very neat don't forget to save oh it
auto saves at the beginning of the day but i will save again
oh actually let's grab uh not new oh i thought this was like
a guy with the bug eyes let's grab our christmas movies
before i forget Let's also get the Red-Nosed Marine, because
it just goes hard.
The Red-Nosed Marine.
Marrying my machine.
Giving my clairvoyant for Christmas.
The Waitlifters.
Waitlifters only Christmas card.
The Last Dinosaur in Blackwood Manor!
I gotta get it.
A cozy monster holiday!
The machines want the syringe.
Okay, we got some good movies here.
Save again.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
But yeah.
Thank you guys so much for today as well.
I hope you guys enjoyed all the cozy chaos.
That is...
That is Retro Rewind.
We will be back.
for more.
I don't know if I will quote unquote unlock everything and
complete the game or whatever, whatever, but as long as I'm
having fun with it, as long as I'm not burnt out from it,
then we'll keep coming back to it.
So, yay!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a good day, have a good night.
Have a good time zone!
Yay!
This is a great one.
I'm glad you liked it!
Thank you!
Please welcome back!
Thank you guys.
Streams have been super cozy.
I just, I...
There's like something addicting.
I like watching these too.
Rick and Dad, thank you!
I like watching these too because there's just something
kind of addicting about like the process of it all.
I don't know.
I like watching streamers play these types of games so I'm
glad that you like watching me play as well.
Thank you so thank you!
Thank you bro.
Oh wait, oh, oh.
It just, it just crashed.
The tab just crashed.
No!
Wait, I think I can read it through.
Wait, no, Takizo, you also sent a dono.
I'm so sorry.
Some pizza finds for my cute ghost Oishi.
Thank you for a really fun stream.
Work has been really rough lately.
You've been making my day a lot better.
I really appreciate you.
Me no, Takizo!
Sorry, work has been rough.
no no no i'm glad that i can do any little bit to help
though for everybody too i feel like so many people lately
have been like ah it's been kind of bad time recently and
i'm like no but i hope that you know if anything i hope a
stream or two or five or 20 can help with taking off a
little bit of the stress on your brain and maybe it make you
giggle a little and maybe it make you forget about some
stuff so but hang in there yeah hang in there i'm rooting
for you yeah you gotta you gotta stay good so that i can
steal your life force you know 20 streams is that a promise
yeah i'll do 20 streams I'll do more than that.
I don't even know how many streams I've done.
I do.
The way I, um, I num, or rather I, uh, name my thumbnails is
by number.
And today was number 420.
It's not entirely accurate because sometimes I use like
other computers or sometimes, uh, sometimes like I'll get a
thumbnail made for me or something.
So it's not entirely accurate, but.
no way today for the for my own purpose though today is 420
that's so funny
so yeah yeah yeah yeah we have um we have uh i've done i've
done about 20 streams i've done about 20 streams so far uh
in my career so that's really cool what was my 67th let's
see why would you ask that actually it was eternal darkness
and my 69th was mgs2 any
other any other curiosities
paragon paragon paragon somehow that makes so much sense for
you does it sorry that cough was my ectoplasm getting in my
throat store is still open I want to rent a dinosaur movie
yeah I will have Ryan take care of you while I'm gone 21st
left for dead 2 with Haruka and Matawa and Hanya 4th was Oh,
what is this game called?
The Melons game.
The game where you can't say melons.
310?
Minto was Walking Dead.
Part 5.
Facade!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
444th.
Uh-oh.
Someone can't count.
I said we're on 420, buddy.
We're on 420!
No!
First karaoke?
Hmm.
Isn't that number one?
The very first one?
The first stream back, I did some karaoke.
I think, though, I did do a Dempagumi karaoke.
That was number 12.
And then I did a karaoke.
Karaoke.
Karaoke after that was number 13.
i have like so much like i have so much stuff i kind of
hoard everything how big is this folder let's see it is my
folder where i keep everything is 145 gigs actually that's
not that bad i think for everything that i have saved if
you're like oh minto like what if something what about
something from like the oldest the olden times like the
oldest times yeah i have it all i have the thank yous i have
the thank yous for that everyone did from my discord server
like i have those all saved i have everybody's profile
pictures saved from those two for some reason
yeah um Like, there were cute little pictures like this.
Look at that guy.
I have...
What else here?
I have the first time Pikami modded me.
She gave me the wrench and I was really excited.
And so I screen-shotted it and I still have that.
And then I have the time that...
I collabed with Peekami.
And that's me right next to her.
And I was really excited that I was next to her on her
stream.
So I screen-shotted that.
And...
I have a...
Let's see.
Whoops.
What else do I have in here?
I like the...
those ones a lot.
I have when I first got 10,000 subscribers!
That was exciting.
That was an exciting time.
Yippee!
Yeah, baby.
Now I have like 10 times that.
Wait.
Yeah.
And then I have this.
I have I have fan games that people made for me I have old
graphics I have all my old thumbnails even That's crazy work
Wait I should probably delete the PSD files Of these at
least And I have all my old schedules Let's see, what did I
do?
March 27th
Oh I think this was like Right when I graduated for the
first time I played Phoenix Wright and stuff and Friday
Night Funkin.
Yeah.
I just didn't, I just, I think I ignored Sunday.
Congrats on 10k subs!
Thank you!
Yay!
I'm so, I have like, if you're like, dang, she probably
doesn't have this.
I probably have it.
Oh no, this is my final.
Wait!
March 29th Oh my gosh, it's almost my previous graduation
day Because I graduated on 4-4 On April 4th Getting closer
to 4-4-4 K7 I know!
We're slowly but surely, right?
Mm-mm-mm So We did a membo And finished Phoenix, right?
I did a collab And then Saturday was my final stream Look at
that That's so sad so literally literally four years ago
four or five years wait when was this 2021 right yeah 2021
years ago this week was me getting ready for by graduation
isn't that kind of crazy oh it is five years ago it's 2026
five years ago yeah wow guys this is my schedule for this
week?
Wait a second, does it line up?
So close!
Oh my gosh, wait, I could use this next year.
I could use this next year.
What if I just start reusing my old schedules for for next
year?
It's like, oh, what am I doing?
What am I doing on January?
We're doing Slytherio!
And a manga!
An Ace Attorney 3!
We just do the whole, we just do it all over again.
Replaying all the old games.
What if it's like a collab with people that don't exist
anymore?
What do, what do, what do?
And then, oh my gosh, this is like super ancient, right?
But I did like a Membushhip thing where when I first opened
the memberships and if i got it was a membership athon and
if i got i think i don't remember actually how many i got to
but the first 44 members got a special custom vip card i
know some of you still have it april fools right right i
missed that first year so i'm all for it yeah Obviously, I
wouldn't do something like this again.
If I did, like, something, it would be, like, a charity.
Kind of, you know, like, if we hit a goal of something,
something, it would be for charity.
But...
I saw Snaff!
Thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you.
But, yeah.
Yeah.
Um...
Well, it got me on this topic.
I don't even remember.
Can you still do the Toad voice?
What?
What was the Toad?
Oh, I read Dono's as Toad voice for the rest of stream!
Was I crazy?
I could.
Uh, what should I say?
What should I say?
Oh, looking back on streams.
Actually, my voice is kind of messed up right now, so maybe
I shouldn't.
flam i got flam you had to skip a chapter of ace attorney
and didn't do rise from the ashes to finish the series in
time those were fun times oh gosh wait i don't even remember
that that's crazy to remember that oh my goodness jonathan
welcome to bamboo ship thank you i got no it's not flam it's
ectoplasm uh but yeah it's kind of crazy looking back on all
this stuff like like you at this too like like for the
example like this this this collab like maria like we were
collabing together and everything um and yeah oh look at
this look at this i did i got 1000 subscribers i don't know
why i'm closing my eyes in the picture I don't know why I'm
closing my eyes in the picture.
Crazy work.
Why did it take it like that?
I could have redone it.
She blinked for the photo.
And now you're close to 500k.
Well, I'm not close, but we're getting there.
We're getting there.
If I could get to 500k, that would be so crazy.
crazy so so crazy oh my gosh why are your hands down i don't
know actually okay my hands back then i was such a small
spirit that like i could have my hands up but i could not
conjure my hands down so like if i tried to put my hands
down because i had so low spirit energy my hands would just
disappear so i'm so In that image, my hands are just, my
arms are nubs.
Wait, I can show you.
I can show you right now, I think.
Wait, hold on.
This one?
I have to find it.
Oh, why have I have glasses on?
That's crazy.
Okay, hold on.
Let me find it.
I become, I become arm.
I get the mega, mega, mega.
Make a, make a nub.
Wait, let me find it.
Uh.
Wait, wait a second.
No!
Wait, why wouldn't it work?
I don't know.
Never mind.
It only has this.
Retro Minto.
Wait, I I should use this model for one of the streams!
No, it's so embarrassing.
It's actually way too embarrassing.
It's actually so embarrassing.
You guys seeing me like this.
It's so embarrassing.
It does kind of remind you of like a simpler time though,
right?
When like I'm super stiff.
And like, my Algae does not even, it barely bounces, you
know, like it barely moves.
It reminds me of like, it truly is the 2020 VTuber
aesthetic.
It really is.
Can you lower your mic quality?
Yeah, I'll get like a, I'll get actually, I'll get Toaster
Mic back and everything.
I, I, I would hadn't, when I first started streaming, I had
no idea about streaming.
And so I recorded my intro video with like a nice mic set
up, quote unquote nice, you know, for the time.
But nice for me at the time.
But I thought with streaming, I was like, oh, every streamer
uses like a headset mic, probably.
And so I remember on my first stream, I had the headset mic
and I was using it.
And everyone was like, whoa, what happened?
It's 2021, there's Ace Attorney.
Past, Minto, present, Minto, Minto, cute, all the same.
Thank you.
Actually, this hairstyle, hmm.
Kind of maybe making a comeback.
Wait a second.
Kind of maybe.
Next outfit.
Crazy.
um now i look at it but uh and then i remember i remember
making this like this background where is it this one i
remember making it at work i remember making it like i was i
was like oh i want to i want my own little why did i make it
like this i don't know but I thought it was kind of cute.
Squares.
Be there or be square.
I posted an old image of your toggle in Minto Live.
Why do you have that, Paige?
Why do you have that?
No!
So goofy though.
So goofy looking at me like this.
Oh my god.
You really did.
That...
I have no...
I had... I look so innocent as my...
As I become a member of Kadawa Shoujo.
I just realized the time.
Sorry.
I've been... I've been...
What's wrong with your hands?
No!
I just realized the time and everything.
if my skirt barely moves anything barely moves everything's
barely moving i'm glad i wasn't the only one thinking that i
have ghost hands is meet the one also by ayami mama no no no
can you break out the children the children's joke book okay
for real now ozumito thank you Thank you so much for hanging
out with me today!
Midnight Plant Drive.
Mario, thank you so much for the 10 get- Let me get this
image off the...
Thank you so much for the 10 get it!
Happy to catch a stream, working nights is rough.
Oh, Steen, have a good shift.
Good luck.
Me too, always cute, even when stiff.
I was really proud of this outfit though.
I designed it, you know?
I like sent it to an artist and I was like, please make me.
And here I am.
I was made six years ago.
I only joined after the return, so I quite like.
Thank you.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the time you get to thank
you.
I was dissed from a toaster mic on a laptop in a closet.
look how far you've come i know literally i was in my closet
on my laptop my gaming laptop on my toast on my toaster mic
and then now i'm i'm doing all kinds of things crazy so
crazy okay have a good day have a good night and i'll see
you when i see you next time bye bye Bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, bye-bye.
Wait, wait, I'm gonna...
Wait, actually, at a time like this, it calls for a truly
classic, Minto classic ending.
I think.
One second.
This is how I used to close out every stream.
Oh.
Oops, I paused it.
If there's something strange, sleeping in your bed.
If there's something weird, sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Busting makes me feel good.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting, busting,
busting, busting, busting, busting, Busting, Busting,
Busting, Busting, Busting.
Busted, Busted!
Busted!
If you're feeling things, sleeping in your bed.
Yeah!
The reasonable man!
Saving in your bed.
Oh!
Let me tell you some.
O!
Yeah!
Make me feel good.
Feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good Man.
Freaking man, baby.
Don't all alone.
Let me sleep in your bed.
Shoo!
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I'm afraid of no sleep.
I'm afraid of no bed.
I'm gonna order my pizza now.
In a visible bed.
Freaky ghost bed Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah I don't really want pizza anymore But
nothing else is open What is the ghost to do?
Midnight pizza Feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good
Yeah, Taco Bell Okay That's probably A little better than
eating pizza.
Feel garlic, feel garlic, feel garlic, feel garlic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Burstin, Burstin, Burstin, Burstin, Burstin, Burstin,
Burstin, Burstin, Burstin, Burstin, Wish you could cook for
me!
You could and I could possess you.
You could!
Burstin,
Burstin, Burstin, Taco Bell, Taco Bell, Taco Bell, Taco
Bell, Taco Bell, Taco Bell, Makes me feel good, feel good,
feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good Busted makes me
feel good, thank you everyone, bye bye, bye, for some thank
you, thank you, bye bye.